[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what is up what is good how you living
how you feeling how you doing welcome
inside the final four here in NRG arena
in Houston it is
final four live presented by Wendy's and
I have two dudes that would whoop you
absolutely whoop you in pickleball or
basketball right now this is a former
USA Basketball male athlete of the year
he was the star of Purdue Robbie frickin
Hubble and to his left a champion in
2009 a three-team first team
All-American his number is in the
rafters down there at North Carolina
Tyler frickin hansborough I'm lefko it's
good to have you here they just did I
get a better intro for you that's all I
need
I'm just a guy bro they're announcing
the starters right now what we're gonna
do is we're watching the game along with
you we're having our Wendy's they are
very prepared they have seen these games
Tyler's gonna argue about Blue Bloods
we're gonna make sure we iron that out
and we know who is a blue blood and not
a blue blood because we have a lot of
teams that have never been here before
the number of the final four if you add
up all their seating 23 the second
highest it's ever been a four seed two
fives and a nine FAU trying to be the
first nine seed to even make it to a
Finals game but it is FAU San Diego
State I just want to get your guys
initial reaction of the final four
because we're here with you guys all
night these four teams it's a different
type of atmosphere don't you think well
totally different from last year where
we've got all the Blue Bloods whether
that's traditionally or that's the guys
that have played like Blue Bloods over
the last 10 15 20 years where you have a
final four last year with Duke and
Carolina and Villanova and Kansas this
year it's totally different but I think
it makes sense when you think about the
parody we saw across college basketball
and when when the talent level is so
across the board similar you get results
like this where you've got a nine seed
playing a fight seat in our first game
but I think it'll still be just as fun
just as enjoyable so much is on the line
and and Tyler knows as well as anybody
when you're out here playing on Saturday
or Monday night the stakes are never
higher regardless of who is playing yeah
this is the biggest stage uh I preferred
last year's final four a little more
than this year obviously you know the
Carolina was there but no it has been a
story of the Cinderellas and I think you
know when you talk about nil and you
talk about the new uh landscape of
college basketball I think this could be
a new normal especially for teams like
San Diego State who have a lot of
experience and older players with the
extra covert year I think you're
starting to see guys with experience uh
you know kind of excel at this and this
can be a fun game and I think as long as
the coveted year is in play yeah this is
going to be a very normal occurrence
because you've got guys we've got a guy
out here tonight is 25 years old he's
playing that's wild it is yeah it's uh
it's crazy I think the average age for
San Diego State might be like 22-23 yeah
so there are a bunch of older guys
obviously uh from a physicality
standpoint they let you have it they're
dominant oh yeah that was going to be
one of my locks was how many time we
refer to San Diego State as a football
team uh let's we we made locks we wanted
to make predictions to keep ourselves
honest we each have submitted two locks
for each game Robbie do you want to go
first with your locks your picks for who
you got well I'm going to go I actually
might need to put them on the screen
because I think we forgot what our picks
were the numbers I'm not totally sure
what I said I do know I've got in the
first game yes black so we needed we
need this on the screen because I don't
know what my locks are so please put
them on the screen well what what were
the ins oh there it is okay Robbie's
okay I got San Diego State to win by
five plus yes I think I think they're
going to get it done their defense their
physicality their continuity they their
average age Tyler and I were talking
about this coming up I think the fact
that they have great positional size
with that physicality that would be hard
for an FAU team that can get a little
bit loose with it we saw against Kansas
state if they turned the ball over like
that's going to be a long deal and then
tremel 10 and a half over on the points
all right game's about to start we will
be talking about it but I want quickly
do you remember what your locks were
we'll get them on the screen right now
uh mylocks I think I had uh yes FAU
under 64.5 Points San Diego State one of
the best defensive teams in college I
think they can hold them under that and
then I got John L Davis under 13 and a
half points I think their defense is too
much I know he's a leading scorer yeah
uh FAU but those are my big sweet 16 and
then kind of went quiet for the elite
eight and the sweet 16 in the big round
of 32. uh mylocks I pretty much rode
with both of you guys said I think it's
a low scoring game totals 131 as Florida
Atlantic hits a three and that is big
because San Diego State has not been
allowing threes my other one is it's
kind of a joke but I think three or more
times we're gonna see San Diego State
dive on the ground really low number
yeah I didn't know what to say to that
it might be in the first half time out
here all right so the game is officially
started uh Florida Atlantic hit the
three they were able San Diego State to
hold all of their opponents to like two
of 28 3 of 15. in those four games
opponents are shooting 17 from three
against the San Diego State Defense so
for that shot to go down early that's
certainly big for a team that wants to
play loose and free Tyler I'm curious
you guys watch wow the floating hook
shot right now by the way whoever set up
the studio getting the big board right
behind us where it feels like the game
is behind us also like this is great
here's the floater uh here's actually
the first three and San Diego State just
answered with a three of their own and
he's been cold as of late they need to
get him going because Matt Bradley last
three game just six points a game 22
from the field and hasn't made a three
and he's a guy that was first team all
Mountain West this season so they need
him to score pretty impressed to see
that they've been able to win without
him doing his thing offensively so Tyler
apparently looking back at the final
four the this first game the semi-finals
are typically higher scoring than the
elite eight games having played in a few
of these what is this first game
atmosphere like is it nervous is it let
me go out there and because you've had a
week between the elite eight and the
final four well for me let's let's get
the game going I mean you've had media
you've had open practices yes you've had
to answer questions for a whole week
yeah everyone's hitting you up for
tickets it's let's just tip the ball off
and you know for me it's just a big
relief when I was in the final four and
I I can see this for both teams
especially uh you know these schools
this is the biggest stage they've ever
been on and so I cannot imagine how many
people are hitting them up for tickets
and what they've been through with the
media in particular this week how much
did you feel the ramp up because when
you go from the first week into the
second there's a noticeable difference
in terms of how many people are covering
and then when you get here how much
different is the second weekend to the
final four weekend uh the final four
weekend is a huge difference and the
reason I say that is because the open
public practice is a big deal so you not
only you have practice off-site
somewhere like a high school or whatever
and then you come over here to the
actual Arena and then you have a public
practice obviously you're not going to
do the same things in the public
practice that you would do in the
private because then there's some some
teams might Scout you but it is
exhausting just all the travel it's a
huge difference uh and I think the
practices have a lot to do with that one
thing that we want to do on this show is
we want you guys to be engaged I have an
iPad the best comments are coming to
this iPad I'm going to read them if
they're questions I will ask them but if
they're not good I'm going to be honest
you're trash and we're gonna throw out
your comments very direct because to the
point yeah and if you want to come at me
it's okay I'm not going to see you but
we'll try another big three for San
Diego State Bradley with the first
Bradley with the second was that Bradley
yeah it was he didn't even play in the
second half against Creighton I mean he
and it wasn't because he was injured it
was because he wasn't playing well and
they went with other guys what a great
start for Matt Bradley okay so when you
guys watch games you see it differently
than I do can you tell in the first five
minutes the the way a game is going to
go or is this is it the first five
minutes different than the rest of the
game well I think you know we're at the
First Media timeout almost and we have
11 points so it's like it's gonna be
yeah it's gonna be the slow grind and
we've seen some shots go down even early
here but they're they're gonna San Diego
State wants to spread this thing out and
they want to take time off the clock on
offense and and grind you down can you
get affiliate of this game for me uh
well San Diego State for Matt Bradley
come out and hit two big threes I mean
the guy their leading scorer who has
been struggling the past two games like
uh Robbie just said
for him to hit those two threes to begin
with that means he's got his confidence
he put his work in that's a good sign
for San Diego State uh early on and in
particular San Diego State likes to play
the kind of
ugly physical that was sorry yeah that
was a scud missile
that was terrible I won
you know you know what's crazy I came in
all week thinking I was going to root
for FAU and I'm finding myself pulling
for San Diego State right here your
money's on the line you said that oh I
don't even care no that's man when
you're left coach you don't even care
about your bed in your life exactly baby
uh I I think it's just not like I'm
watching San Diego State play and I'm
seeing FAU kind of stand on the outside
and wait to shoot and maybe it's a
stylistic type of thing
um we actually I want to go to the polls
really quick we have a who you got poll
um right now let's just start one FAU
San Diego State let's get that thing
going I know I want to know where you
guys are voting which way you guys are
gonna go uh all right you're in the
finals first time out coach brings you
over can you take yourself back to that
moment of of your first final four and
the lessons that were like what was that
energy like well my first final four was
in San Antonio we played Kansas and we
absolutely came out and uh got off to a
horrendous start so we were down big in
the hole so that first time out I was
absolutely exhausted if you know coach
Williams coach Williams doesn't call
timeouts uh so that would have he lets
you guys figure it out he will not call
a timeout never has never it's it's not
his style wow uh so I mean that first
time out was a media timeout we were we
came out into the hole I mean it took us
a while we're just too exhausted yeah
but you know to set the tone to begin
with is a huge deal especially in
college in the NBA you can fight back a
leader teams down 20-2 and then they win
the game by 15. college is a little
different so okay so follow-up question
for you you're in the hole when do you
what momentum is a real thing when did
you feel it changing like was it a shot
was it something he drew up like how did
it turn
well you got to Chip Away there wasn't a
shot
um but you can't get caught up in trying
to make a home run play the best thing
to do is Chip Away get easy buckets yeah
get your confidence up maybe get to the
foul line or get some layups and then
those other shots will come around but
in particular that game I think Danny
Green had a top of the uh yeah top of
the key three power that just kind of
went out that would have been a big
momentum changer for us so we were just
we were just exhausted Danny Green is
the king of hitting those huge parties
yeah uh Lou three two five five is FAU
the most disliked low seed we've ever
seen
I think what he's saying is is you know
when 11 seed George Mason gets here it's
undoubted who everybody's rooting for
but does FAU not have as much love I
also think luge is trying to be a hater
that sounds like a San Diego State fan
yeah I haven't felt that no they don't
think anybody's been anti-fa youth here
they've had love all year yeah I mean
they're top 25 I think at one point and
then you know the David versus Goliath
Story I mean you know these are two
Davids to be honest with you either one
of them have been on this stage but like
you said ranked in the regular season
they won 35 games I I do think that they
were under seated I think it's fair to
say that with their performance here and
with their their record their resume
that maybe they should have been a nine
seed but with the way their bracket
broke they should be thankful they were
a nine seed with a 16 in the second
round that actually worked out big time
yeah you didn't have to see it one head
coach at FAU Dusty may this program has
never won a tournament game ever before
this they just started having men's
basketball in D1 in 1988 which
I think is when Rick Robbie was born I
was 89 but uh don't disrespect gotcha
gotcha gotcha no points last four
possessions for FAU they're all just
standing around the three-point line the
drive the finish and FAU is on the board
Robbie did you cover both of these teams
this year this is my first team seeing
them live and in post time I saw San
Diego State last year in the N state
tournament when they lost to Creighton
and they are basically the same core
this would be a huge shot for Matt
Bradley this is crazy to see him play
like this with the way he struggled in
that Creighton game all right I'm going
to share a degenerate story I bet one
college basketball game all year and it
was New Mexico over San Diego State on a
tip and I was like this Matt Bradley guy
is killing me and now I'm back watching
him and again he's got three threes I
gotta ask why why was that the one game
that you did because I was in the
Bahamas and I was in a sports book and
it was like door in the middle of the
bay and I just hit up my friend and he's
like I really like New Mexico and it
yeah okay yeah Tim you owe me uh about
100 miles away this guy right here man
Bradley with 11.
that's the thing about Bradley though
whether he's driving it or he's in the
post he wants to get back to that strong
left hand they run great stuff for him
and dribble handoffs but with his size
they'll post him too no field goals for
the FAU owls in the last four minutes
that one was huge
wait a second why did they take off that
layup from earlier
right weren't they at seven already I
thought they were five okay I'm crazy uh
I'll go to Big Kenny in the app who ask
what's the vibe in the building more FAU
or San Diego State we were discussing
this earlier it was kind of hard to tell
I there was some it sounded like booze
first I I actually I will say this the
FAU fan section goes about three or four
rows deeper what are you saying Tyler
FAU I think FAU every time they score
when they did the lineups I think it's a
little uh towards FAU right now I would
agree I do think San Diego state has the
better chance though
they were doing like the Atlanta Braves
type of vibe and a little bit ago but
FAU coming back here comes a hockey sub
this is one of my favorite Subs just
pull them all and bring everybody in
Matt Bradley go to that why would you do
that that's these both these teams
Florida Atlantics got the second deepest
bench in the country and San Diego State
is the 22nd so both these teams will go
into that bench they're deep and both
these coaches not afraid to kind of
alternate mix and match lineups that's
crazy they did the hockey sub not even
at a timeout that was just a normal
so I guess when you have the depth is it
the second unit is used to playing
together so you keep them all together
you don't just kind of bring them in
throughout the game I'm trying to think
we did a game in the in the first week
in the NCAA tournament where it was
Howard and their second unit was
substantially worse than their first
right but they were never mixing and
matching so every time the second unit
came in it was like that lead would get
built out by Kansas and then the first
unit would come back it was yeah
interesting strategy I think it's
actually to an advantage and you've seen
some teams that don't use their bench
and then come tournament time they have
some injuries and they have to play more
foul trouble playing and they can't
really get a rhythm but I mean it's a
good thing to be this deep because
you're not too dependent on one player
either you guys can stay healthy so I
actually I I like it
hey man Jane lady is not bashful he just
got in and took a shot and I promise you
he touched it again that bad he's gonna
shoot it again Up Now San Diego State I
think like they got a bunch of guys that
are all averaging like six seven points
there really isn't a guy as FAU has
crawled back into this game now down
just two
14-12
their offense though is fun to watch the
ball moves from side to side they've got
multiple guys that can drive you and
Janelle Davis has kind of been the guy
that's got in the pub but Elijah Martin
can really go as well
you know now I'm kind of to the point
where before I was excited about Bradley
and now I'm like who else is going to
step up besides Bradley
San Diego State getting there yes
there's your guy I told you he's around
the ball man
is that the scouting report on him well
I saw him in Ohio State didn't play a
lot and he was at TCU and had to sit out
a little bit been injured but you watch
their games when he touches that thing
it's it's going to pass it is to shoot
Tyler I feel like you would like to play
for the San Diego State team I feel like
they play the way that you play wow
another big three from FAU I tell you
what FAU is coming back they're getting
their momentum they like I said early on
they've got some easy buckets now you're
starting to see him hit some threes but
no I I do like to watch the physical uh
basketball that's why I like them uh
when they played against Tennessee I
thought that was going to be a really
good Clash of styles just two bangers
going up against each other so
wow wow Ladi again
taking it right to the basket getting
the contact I think this is the Under 12
minute timeout actually uh I want to
kind of look back at how these teams got
here again this is final four live
presented by Wendy's Wendy's they do
Burgers right everyone else that sells
you a circle Burger they're cheating you
out of four corners anyway FAU the run
to how we got here uh it's been exciting
of course some big time upsets
um this was the big game I think against
Memphis of course they had the upset in
round one
um oh no this was it it meant everyone
loved Memphis advancing yeah oh they're
long we're going to talk about how
Purdue couldn't handle the not that it
mattered because they wouldn't have
played him in the second game anyway but
that's the game-winner by Nick Boyd I
mean they've had a heck of a run but
they've trailed in all four of their
games in the second half and they've
just found ways to keep coming what kind
of confidence does that give you well I
mean huge confidence this was the
match-up that you were talking about
[Applause]
Tennessee is as physical as anybody and
with their bigs in the fact that Florida
Atlantic took those guys on yeah match
that physicality and drove that
physicality pretty impressive stuff
especially Tennessee coming off after
beating Duke
Duke it's kind of a hot team at the time
but yeah it was uh you know I had
tendency beating them on that one but
FAU came through and that was a big win
for him got to give him some confidence
too we're gonna have this guy on the
show in a little bit Marquis who just
won Bob Cousy point guard of the Year
award uh I really thought I I don't know
why he passed that I wanted him to shoot
that three I'm surprised he did just
because of the way he'd played at the
guard right yeah I may have had overtime
at plus 1200 in that game uh really
would have loved that second ever
tournament appearance for FAU first
final four in program history first
Conference USA team in Final Four since
I believe it was the Derrick Rose team
in Memphis because that's what John
Calipari does
he gets the teams to the final four I
think they might have vacated that one
too
now that was uh I think that was in San
Antonio yeah that was with you guys yeah
so your where did you have did you have
FAU losing in Memphis in the first round
I did Kendrick Davis from Memphis is a
really good Player Pro and to me he was
the best player on either team so I went
with Memphis
I look nobody had FAU doing this nobody
had FAU uh we're sitting here now 16-15
doing a reset eight and a half minutes
in uh if you had to call a friend and
say what has happened so far how would
you explain it to him I would say early
on Matt Bradley set the tone for with
the threes and FAU has answered the run
like Tyler said it started with easy
baskets but now they're spraying it for
some Threes And the fact that they're
three for seven from three early on
against the defense that doesn't give up
shots yeah from the perimeter remember
they went four minutes without a basket
yeah and now they're sitting here
it's not one
Matt Bradley 11 of the 16 points right
now for San Diego State but hockey
substitution so that entire first so if
you're a coach right and you're like but
this is what we do we do the subs but
you're here you're at NRG Stadium
eventually when you go hey I need to
play my guys hey well if I'm the coach
right now Matt Bradley's not on the
bench I don't pull a guy out that's hit
two or three threes in a row let him
cook yeah let them keep going let them
you know spend a little energy then take
them out let him get a breather I don't
do that especially right now as FAU is
climbing their way back man
so who when you when I say San Diego
State is there a player that comes to
mind all time
[Applause]
that's got to be him not even close
because he he's this you know he doesn't
talk super physical can defend anybody
but this is what their program has been
built off it's the defensive end of the
floor
how do you think Kawhi is here I don't
know I don't think so probably not uh we
have a superstar in the building we're
gonna welcome her in a little bit but
she's uh you know she's just trying to
intimidate us right now we're not going
to tell you who it is uh but we will be
having special guests throughout this
incredible final four live presented by
Wendy's all right FAU down to 11 minutes
left they're feeding the big good play
gets it to go and we are tied at 17.
what do you think of the big here guys
Vlad golden uh he's had a pretty good
tournament he's had some big games uh
he's a freshman but I think if he gets
going this could be a plus he's an X
Factor for me for FAU uh outside of uh
John now and Elijah Martin I you know if
they get a lot of production from him I
think it's gonna be a good sign for FAU
how would you defend him I feel like you
just on that last play it's so hard
because when you get a mental post up in
the entry from the top of the key you
can't double it's just one-on-one and
it's right in size he can just go either
hand right over the top because he's
enormous he is huge it's 7-1
yeah it's kind of a lost art being able
to get that deep seal down there you not
have to make a move just go right up
with the hook shot that's old school I
love it yeah
all right
um it is now time to welcome uh one of
my friends uh she's two weeks older than
me
she's kind of cool she's been doing
National Television we'd like to welcome
in to final four live presented by
Wendy's the one the only Candace Parker
oh yeah this is a nice little uh yeah
what do we think a gig up here it's a
sweet so we can order you anything Sam
listen is it on your bills it is okay
all the Wendy's is free though okay deal
if you want any Frosty oh man Frosty's
that was the move all right now that
we're talking about Wendy's after my
basketball practice in high school we
would go to Wendy's I feel like Tyler
you ate really clean after practice what
was your after practice I like a lot of
young hoopers are eating at all what was
the After High School basketball
practice meal for you guys
well from Wendy's they had the triple
cheeseburger which is low-key that thing
was pretty solid and then I heard you
talk about the frost season you take the
fries and dip the fries in the frosties
that's my guy you're not the only one
that that does you don't do that I can't
do it the Sweden that's kind of like the
I just feel like it's lactose
okay so now we're doing it here again
that this is what happened on National
Television you don't dip you don't dip
the fries no I don't dip I like I'm the
person that like on my plate I don't let
anything touch I got compartments yeah
but you do dip a good donut into some
coffee
how old were you in this oh my gosh that
was Tennessee I got the orange little
fleece on yeah that's that's uh that's
Tennessee junior year so because FAU
beat Tennessee
do you root for them more to take it
home or are you hoping that they they
lose
I'm kind of I'm one of those that like I
don't want the team that we lose to to
do well so
uh yeah I think San Diego State in this
game just the way the game is being
played right now
um I think it definitely favors them but
listen Florida Atlantic Tennessee is um
I mean if I can say this a mini San
Diego State I mean in terms of like the
scoring droughts and the lulls and their
defense just kind of getting them
through those possessions Ken's you
played in two of these things you won
both of them you were the two-time most
outstanding player what what's the
pressure like just coming into a week
like this in a game like this on the on
the biggest stage I think the hardest
thing is your focus I mean the focus
after everybody telling you you're the
best ever for an entire week in between
the regional and basically now the final
four so I think it's the focus and then
those first two minutes it doesn't
matter how great a shape you're gonna be
in you're going to be winded and you're
going to be tired your heart's gonna be
going yeah
um there's nothing like it and you know
a lot gets put on making your first shot
yeah really in the big scheme of things
it doesn't matter I think so much is put
on that but these man these two teams
this is this is a moment they're gonna
remember forever how long does it take
you to settle in and finally where
you're not because everybody when the
ball gets thrown up if you're not
everybody if you're not feeling weird
there's almost something wrong with you
yep so how at what point in the game are
you feeling like all right this is
normal I'm out here doing what I'm doing
I say about two minutes would you say
like two minutes maybe give or take I
just get excited when it tips off I'm so
exhausted from everything the media and
the open practices I'm just ready to get
it going so a big relief just when the
ball goes up a thousand percent yeah uh
we have shots being hit uh by San Diego
State what are they from they're four or
five from three yeah this is
unbelievable
the big dude getting it done for FAU
punching it in who was your pick before
the game so I actually picked San Diego
State okay for for my pick before
um both of them did two yeah yeah
defensively you can scheme you can scout
you can talk about what they do but
until you face that physicality and the
way the refs are calling the game now it
favors San Diego State
Michael coffino commenting this is great
are you three chomping on some
baconators would that make it better yes
it would if we had that was my nickname
in high school Baconator
uh Tyler what's the most unexpected part
of going to the final four as a player
asks Lou
what did you not realize was gonna
happen uh probably ticket request uh or
how many close friends hit me up that
you know I hadn't talked to in a while
but you know that's that's always a
little overwhelming but
when you're when you're the star of a
team do people leave you alone or is it
even more so
I think just in terms of a final four
like this yeah if you're a star of a
team you're probably up for National
accolades
lunches yeah Player of the Year you know
Awards and things like that and uh you
know that can get exhausting and in
between the practices like you said the
media you get to the arena I feel like
you live here for two or three days uh
yeah you live here the amount of hours
you're spending here I wanted to ask you
about Caitlyn Clark because you're
you're one of those players that's like
it that was awesome last night oh my
gosh you're in the pantheon of great
players and she's got a long way to go
with her pro career of course but where
how do you view her game especially
after what she did yesterday I think a
lot of people and myself included wanted
to see her do it against the athleticism
do it against the best of South Carolina
I mean South Carolina you see them there
they are just huge and big and athletic
and for her to be able to get her shot
off and do what she did I mean a 41
point at the biggest stage where you are
the key to ever to to be stopped on
every possession for her to do that I
mean
listen she made me a Believer yesterday
and I don't do this but like mentioning
somebody what she's do what she's doing
in this tournament is a la stuff what
Steph did except now she's she's in the
next final right that's a great
comparison that's kind of what I was
thinking too Candace what do you think
about experience for San Diego State
because they don't really have a
McDonald's All-American neither team and
San Diego State sir average age is like
23 they have somebody who's 25 on their
team you know physically they're
stronger a little more you know
defensive uh you know intelligence and
they know the rotations how big of a
factor you think that's played for their
run and while you talk about it we're
going to relive their run to the final
four so we're gonna give you some video
to talk over but all right to answer
Tyler's question no I think experience
is huge uh at this point in in the
tournament I mean we've seen that now
the mid Majors that are able to have
those older guys come play basketball
um be able to come in with some sort of
experience there's a huge difference
playing 24-25 against 18 19. that's all
crazy there's a huge difference in that
um and so I think just in terms of
especially understanding what you have
to do to win a lot of people think
flashy plays shots whatever it literally
comes down to one or two possessions and
that rebound might happen in in the
midpoint of the first half it may not
happen at the end of the game it might
you know so I think your experience
allows you to know when it's the time to
make those plays and you're seeing in
San Diego State those guys trust in that
and and wanting to make those plays even
in the middle of the game and this one
over Bama like shocker well they were
down late and then just grinded their
way back and made some shots at a key
time and they're just a tough group man
and you know what they lost a
heartbreaking game last year to
Creighton in the NCAA tournament and
sometimes as a player and a team you've
got to go through a devastating loss not
that you want it but you learn from it
and then the next year you're in a game
like this where it's late and they they
make every play down the stretch I
remember right around the first four we
were talking about how important it is
for a team to lose somewhat later in the
year so that you can have that
conversation we don't want to feel this
again how many when do you ever see a
team go right through their conference
tournament right through their
conference and then they experience that
that fear at the end first final four in
program history first Mountain West team
to make the final four try that one is
crazy we haven't had a national
championship since 1995 perfect time to
bring out what Tyler brought up before
the show we were we were just calling
teams Blue Bloods and because he went to
North Carolina he's like who are the
real Blue Bloods and he said is UCLA a
blue blood because they really haven't
done it in a while
Candace your thoughts as a women's Blue
Blood program Tennessee I I agree with
you I think if you know you haven't done
it
in a long long time so what's the time
is it 10 20
well I would make Yukon almost more
relevant of a blue blood than UCLA I
mean they're about to get there what's
UConn got five Nationals
yeah five since 98 yeah that won over uh
total I think yeah yeah is that Duke
four 99 okay so how long is so you say
UConn's more of a blue blood than UCLA
currently yes
so who would you say the Blue Bloods are
North Carolina Duke North Carolina
Kansas yep I would even go with Kentucky
would you put he doesn't Tyler's not
sure I had a little bit of pushback won
the tournament game in three years until
this year uh I expected him to have a
better season returning the national
player of the year yeah a little bumpy
start in the SEC but they figured out
they got a little bit of a run I'm just
not there with Kentucky I mean I think
the last sticky on Kentucky I mean the
fact they haven't won a tournament game
and they've lost to St Peters who'd they
lose to this year I don't think
[Applause]
they lost to oh my goodness these games
are all like running together
um we'll figure it out hold on
this is real for thunderdog back to Big
Blue Nation all right so are there any
other Kansas State Kansas State oh yeah
um
I mean I can't can you think of any
other Blue Bloods that you'd put in that
conversation they struggle with UCLA
because John Wooden coached there and
Kareem yes but at what point no
argument
is Villanova a blue blood that's I mean
they can make an argument they've been
to a couple final fours but don't you
think the the criteria is too that
you've been to every incidentally
tournament as well because then would
you put
no I'm talking about Villanova no but
I'm saying Villanova didn't make it this
year you know so North Carolina yeah I
wasn't I wasn't going there I promised
Tyler I wasn't if Gonzaga had won one of
those final fours or national
championship games would they be in the
car I mean they've they've had an
incredible run without the top level
success so if you had one of those would
that be enough to make them a blue blood
but now with the transfer portal being
as powerful as it is I think we're gonna
have to change the way yeah so Kevin
Brockway commented and he said how do
y'all feel about the transfer portal uh
wow Florida Atlantic another three I
just want to remind you again San Diego
State has now been allowing threes this
entire tournament FAU turning it on
again Matt Bradley in that first unit
back on the floor FAU has roared back
they're now up six
32-26. oh wow air ball great Petty play
there by Bradley to keep it SDSU ball
um the hardest thing for me in this
tournament was pulling up a roster and
then in the former School category
seeing like three different schools for
so many different players what is your
your Vibe of the transfer portal been as
someone that is like Mr North Carolina
and would never transfer and I feel like
if you had a child and they thought
about going to Duke you wouldn't let
them live in your house so what is it
like for you to see the transfer portal
well I think that uh in particular for
me I think if if you allow coaches to
leave mid-season they do it in football
Notre Dame's head coach left for LSU I
think you cannot allow you cannot deny a
player of that right so I think they're
they should be able to transfer I don't
like when they did it they did it right
after selection Sunday I think it should
be when The Season's totally done with
uh I don't know I'm not the biggest fan
because you know I kind of feel like if
you come in as a freshman and you have a
core group of guys and you work there
for you know work out with each other
for a few years I just feel like that
sense of you could build something
that's pride is kind of lost and I don't
feel a lot of people care about like
Candace I'm sure you you have extreme
Pride for Tennessee I'm not sure these
kids nowaday like you with Purdue kind
of have that that might be missing which
you know I you know I don't like but I
think there's some some positives of
facing adversity and look I'm very proud
you know that more than 5 freaking
anybody no no for sure but I'm very Pro
Player and I think what Tyler said is so
accurate if the coach leaves fair game
you went to play for this person they
leave you should be out of here I also
think your point of that the portal
opening during the NCAA tournament we're
talking about players transferring and
we've got our product down here that's
what we should be celebrating yep why
can't the portal open in three days and
then we have it after the season I think
that's an issue but to go through some
struggle and fight through it now
there's also situations where I'm like
all right it's not working it's time to
move on I think there's a happy medium
there but I hate the fact that all right
I got yelled out of practice portal or
like I'm I'm not playing great for one
week portal I think that there is some
some positives out of some struggle I
want you to comment on it I just wanted
to look up the stat before I said it FAU
right now has I believe six threes
Alabama
had three for the entire game and
Creighton had two for the entire game so
right now FAU has more threes than the
last two teams combined it was three of
27 for Alabama and two of 17 and FAU
already has six which if you had money
on FAU
you're feeling pretty good uh transfer
portal what'd you think
I think that they need to be I I agree I
think that you should be able to
transfer and in the rule it says once
twice you would have to sit out of here
I think that they're they're allowing
they're giving waivers for the second
transfer too easily so I would like them
to to kind of strengthen their rules
around that yeah but I do believe I mean
listen sometimes there's not a fit just
as with with athletes you're guaranteed
one year the next year the coach would
say hey we're going in a different
direction scholarships are one year and
so plans change you bring in another guy
that you know is a top recruit that you
didn't expect and you want to play
basketball and you're seeing a lot of
guys go to big schools and then transfer
to Mid majors and have success and so I
just you know I just look at it as a way
now coaches are going to have to really
get in the transfer portal they are and
a lot of that I think the rules are
gonna have to tighten up a little bit
with that all right Candace feu up 36-28
330 left in the first half what's your
read how does San Diego State closed
this half
here's the thing if I'm FAU you don't
want half time you want to keep riding
this wave because when San Diego State
goes back into the locker room
I can I can only imagine what that
locker room halftime talk is gonna be so
you don't want to face them coming out
listen we always talked about how they
have to hit open threes which they
didn't hit in the first half against
Tennessee but were managed to hit it in
the second half
um and so I just I mean I think this
read is going towards FAU uh San Diego
State's not going to win in the 70s you
have to score in the uh right now Pace
right now
yeah you guys both had FAU under San
Diego State how do you feel about those
bets now I'm not feeling good my man
tremel has zero points so I'm not
feeling good about that one and when I
had San Diego State winning by five so
that's not looking too hot either yeah a
whole lot of basketball left a lot of
basketball left
uh yes I would like the Tweet about
Candace at Tennessee uh if that is the
one though about the donut dipping we've
already aired it uh that's fine
um I I just I know that we're watching
this game oh here it is don't mind us
just think about Candace Parker's days
at Tennessee people are randomly
thinking about you oh that's listen
there's nothing like March Madness
nothing like it in life is unbelievable
you know that's what I like to ask you
guys
you all played Pro you know what that's
like
but why does this feel different why
does coming to the final four or like go
into your alma mater like why does
college basketball hit different
I think in college it's four years you
have four years of Eligibility four
chances and the pros I feel like you
know it's an extended career
um but also it's just about
you're 18 to 22 years old and this is
your first chance really to be on a big
stage like this is your first audition
for the world yeah and for sometimes
people to fall in love with your story
and Paul I mean you think of
just everybody that you've fallen in
love with in March and then you're able
to then follow them through their career
so I just think March is so special this
is this is a special tournament I think
from a player's perspective too you eat
together you live together ever you go
to class together it is the most unique
time and I actually when I was at Purdue
Brian Cardinal came back and he just won
a championship with the Mavericks and I
I'd blow my knee out twice e'twa Moore's
in the NBA Juwan Johnson the NBA our
team is much different from when I was
last playing right and he was like man
you've got to enjoy this year even
though the team's not the same you're
not physically the same yet but there's
never going to be a time in your life
where you are having this much fun
playing basketball I'm looking at him
like you're playing with dirt Nowitzki
and winning titles and you're saying
this yeah and you know I played in the
NBA for like two years I played overseas
for three but he was right I mean you
are you're just you're living with these
people you're growing with these people
and when you're on a college campus
everyone has the same goal to to make
themselves into something great in their
life whether that's a player a student
yeah a musician everyone is the same age
and everybody is trying to just make
something of themselves that's a really
special time on and off the court same
thing for you I agree with Rob I mean
these are your some of your best friends
who you kick it with after practice you
know you go to parties with you have you
know you're you're a student athlete too
you're going around campus doing stupid
things so you feel more of a connection
not that you didn't do stupid things
when you played in the pros but you know
college you know it's some good times
you do some things
I'm just enjoying your highlights right
now
the shorts which makes the era so let me
ask you let me ask you let me ask you
guys this after a big game okay did you
guys go back to campus and go to class
like in between you know rounds or a big
game or whatever did you go back and go
to class
we were always like Matt Painter was we
win a big game we get in at 3am go to
class go to class and they'd class check
us and stuff now sometimes winning
we went to class but winning would
always if there was a couple guys that
stopped going to class nothing would get
said you lose a game we're not going to
class yeah we got this because like all
of a sudden when you lose a game
everything becomes that that's the
reason why we weren't going to class you
know it's it's one of those deals I'm
the same way
the same I went to class yeah yep um I
mean of course I played for pets though
she wasn't playing no games so what were
the schools that didn't make their kids
go to Club I'm not putting anybody on
blast
do you think do you think Dwayne was
going to class of Marquette uh 100 when
he led Marquette to the final four D
Wade was not going to class I'll call
him out on that okay do you think Shaq
was going to class at LSU no way come on
now
come on now I don't think he's going to
collect an honorary doctor said honorary
doctor all right Sean McManus uh not the
head of CBS Sports but another guy asks
who would win the national championship
if it was a battle between mascots
so it's the owls versus the Aztecs who
wins that battle
[Applause]
okay okay so your friend walks into a
barn what happened
uh the owl would swoop them
[Applause]
there's too much experience with this so
yeah yeah yeah my headset's falling off
I'm so excited said an owl ow that was
great let's Split Decision here from all
right so the other one is a Husky and
then a hurricane I mean yeah we all know
how that that ends up I feel like a
hurricane wins everything yeah I agreed
yeah could an Al beat a hurricane
[Applause]
listen I didn't know if Tyler like we
could find out that Tyler has a fear
about category uh-oh ten point game turn
it over yo what's going on here guys San
Diego State was favored by two and right
now FAU is starting to pull away what
Candace said they don't want this first
half to end
yeah you want to keep this thing rolling
I can't believe they've made six threes
four games San Diego State's given up 17
from three but a lot of times the way
they have played they wear on you so
even the open shots you missed because
you're physically tired absolutely
not Florida Atlantic they look well not
at all and if there's one team that I'm
worried about being down double digits
yeah and coming back and scoring it's
San Diego State
I mean San Diego State gives up on
average 63 points a game
and these guys are on Pace for almost 80
right now with two to play WoW
oh another one
nope
all right what does San Diego State need
to chip away to get it at to feel
comfortable I think what Tyler said get
to the foul line man see some easy
baskets get to the Lane get to the line
we're gonna see how disciplined Florida
Atlantic is and how they in this half
because I think a lot of teams don't in
halves well and a game can go from 10 to
six to four real quick in a minute all
right so let me hear your strategy
because they've been shooting threes are
you wasting the whole clock are you
trying to get to the free throw line
what's your strategy no I just think
you're playing discipline you're not
giving uh San Diego State easy baskets
that's the biggest thing because you
know you want to go into halftime with a
10-point lead so defensively you know
you you don't have to score again going
into halftime but you have to defend and
make sure that you're not giving them
easy buckets they're sure they just
showed a graphic that the first five
minutes
um our guy Bradley had 11 points and
he's had zero since and all I'm thinking
about is that hockey shift change yeah
and the momentum that may have been lost
as San Diego State gets a big layup
there to cut the deficit to eight 113
let's see if the owls use Candace's
discipline here boy no line ball
turnovers here that you just have to
take care of the ball and like Candace
said play discipline in your game wow
not only discipline domination to the
basket Martin and one
I just don't think I've ever seen San
Diego State give up durable penetration
and this just speaks to how Florida
Atlantic is attacking the paint
and their philosophy they want threes or
layups there's no mid-range so Florida
Atlantic is taking it to you and
obviously putting San Diego State on
their heels goodness he's a tank too I
mean he's like six two two ten he could
play anywhere in the country physically
Elijah Martin's he's a stud he's had a
great tournament too
all right misses the free throw 10-point
lead we are officially under a minute
can San Diego State cut into this lead
[Applause]
oh Bradley
where are you going step back nowhere
I don't know
there are a lot of a lot of standing
around
oh my gosh Big Shot college basketball
Corner Pocket three
that's the thing about college
basketball you don't hit a shot all game
and all of a sudden they're falling
40-33 San Diego State could get another
look at this too
how much clock will FAU milk they bring
it back out
okay you want to take the last shot
yourself in offensive rebounding
opportunity
FAU turn around
all right they're gonna get a chance
four seconds left big player Bradley
pull up B6 front rim
that would have been six that would have
been exactly what we said but no that
would have been four oh you're you're so
good at math look at Syracuse honestly
we didn't do much math you know she
didn't go to those classes Florida
Atlantic 40.
San Diego State 33. this was an FAU win
of a first half that felt like a huge
all right can I get if you were the
coach of San Diego State can you look
into the camera camera one please and
tell me how you would motivate them
going into the second half if you want
to like look away get your mind right
and then turn back but I'm like I don't
coach left go that there's the there's
no patience there's no patience left go
no I just think we talk about the threes
tell them we would talk about the threes
that we've given up because honestly uh
I can't just talk to the camera no I
can't I can't motivate I can't give the
secrets away but defensively you know
San Diego State hangs their head on
defense they haven't they've done that
the entire tournament and you can't wait
till the final four to stop stop uh
being a good three-point defense
defending team defensive team there you
go I'm sure though Brian Dutcher is
definitely telling his guys we could not
have played worse in the first half
defensively they were six of 14 from
three and we're all down seven points
yeah so we have so many opportunities we
got 20 minutes to get this thing back
our defense has got to be better we're
gonna have our lulls get to the foul
line get to the basket let our defense
create some offense but we could not
play worth and we are still right here
in this game Tyler do you want to pump
up the team in camera three no I like to
keep the conversation here okay okay
no if I if I'm a coach in San Diego
State first of all I try to get Matt
Bradley involved more he came out real
hot we subbed them out didn't score
since I like to get some easy buckets
and also their defense
they've guarded the three-point line
really well but it seems like their
rotation and their help side FAU is just
spreading them out and penetrating just
getting right to the bucket you need to
have help side defense and you need to
have better rotations to stop their
guards from getting inside and getting
those layups we're gonna see who gets to
the championship on Monday night a
little birdie name Anton told me that
you are going to the championship
tomorrow
and Big Kenny asked Iowa or LSU oh who's
winning the championship tomorrow okay
well here's the thing yeah give us my
parents went to Iowa okay so I grew up a
Hawkeyes fan
um but the SEC LSU is is a lot so uh
see I used to get motivation from what
people would say you know in terms of
like motivation no no but I just mean
you know you listen to The Talking Heads
as I call us and you listen to what they
say and then you get motivation off of
it I'm going to go with LSU who's going
to pull it out SEC yeah yeah I'm gonna
go how many points for Caitlyn oh I
think she easy gets over 35. over 35.
easy yeah but you gotta you gotta make
her not have quality looks you gotta
make her take quantity shots right you
got to make her shoot not a good
percentage high volume yeah how sad do
we think Hawkeye fans are here in the
Candace's parents with Iowa I mean
listen it could be a great thing because
we had I remember go to Iowa yeah
it was a great program but it's not you
know that Summit was the goat it's a
little cold there it's a little chilly
it is always a pleasure appreciate you
guys thank you thank you for letting me
come pick it with you all do you like
frosties
no I just need to know I love frosties
like a lot yeah okay I'm gonna give you
a Parting Gift really yeah seriously
yeah because there were some Wendy's
Employers in here earlier okay and I
have some Willy Wonka tickets here what
I'm giving Candace Parker right now
is a year's supply of free frosties
it's April fools read the back
that's right baby see you can't even
take a gift well Candace Parker wow
competitive they does make that tough to
believe that's what I'm saying I was
like come on man enjoy the frosties
thanks get one for Anton thank you
thanks for the people of Wendy's you're
the bestest all right walk off I can
just turn up and leave oh let us square
up presented by Wendy speaking of
Wendy's uh Matt Bradley we saw had all
11 points in the first five minutes Nick
Boyd nine points three uh threes from
Beyond The Arc uh and an eight Matt
Bradley only being a plus one and plus
minus is shocking to me because I kind
of thought that FAU did most of their
damage with him on the bench I guess it
just shows that when he got back in the
game they they pushed that lead right
you have all the other stats there what
other stats jump out to you
let's see for San Diego State Darian
Trammell this really hurts because of my
pick zero points over three and you're
talking about a guy that lasts three
games 15 points a game 18 of 39 from the
field at 21 against Bama certainly he
has got to play better and give them
something offensively and then honestly
looking at Ford Atlantic the balance I
mean Davis with four Greenlee with three
fourth with two Martin with seven golden
four Boyd nine wow 06 Gaffney three
Weatherspoon two so everyone that's
gotten in the game for Florida Atlantic
has scored they've got contributions
hasn't been just one guy balling it's
been everybody across the board
[Applause]
all right I do have some more questions
here from the chat
let's go with
michigander
what does Robbie think of the big tens
tournament failings
last one when it was Michigan State the
Michigan state blue blood
no yeah I don't think Blue Book I I have
a lot of respect for Izzo you think he's
done a great job I think he's made the
tournament 25 years in a row yes uh
unbelievable coach on his record in the
first round is something like 17 and or
no he's had some yeah he's had some
flame I think all coaches do if you
coach long enough for this tournament
it's crazy enough that everyone's gonna
get dinged with that yeah
uh let's take a look at the first half
highlights see how we got here Tyler I
want you to kind of take us through
these just what you're seeing yeah so
that would be kind of the help side uh
rotations for San Diego State like I
kind of said is they need to get their
rotations intact to prevent their guards
from you know penetrating especially FAU
but also Matt Bradley hitting those two
threes to start the game were huge for
San Diego State then they made that sub
and they haven't really had a good
scoring option since you know that's how
Bradley got started
I would like to see him stay in the game
I think in the final four sometimes
coaches have these predetermined
rotations I think that goes out the
window sometimes in game settings when
guys that's what you were saying though
a lot of guards for FAU just streaking
to the hoop and just having to beat one
guy on their back hip it seems like yeah
and that's the thing is you guard the
three-point line really well and you run
guys off but that doesn't mean you just
give them layups to prevent them from
shooting the three so I think you got to
have some type of you know defense
around the rim maybe that big step up
and prevent that guard make make him
make a pass instead of shooting an easy
layup
big man wearing 50 putting it in that
makes hansborough a little happy
knocking down triples constantly Robbie
well I think also and I'll get to FAU
knocking on the triples and it starts
with their dribble drive and now that
helps coming over they're spraying for
threes it's a bit concerning to me
watching Matt Bradley's makes all three
of those threes just contested jab jab
pull yeah it's not like he's getting and
they're generating open looks those are
just great individual plays that's not a
consistent form of offense no he's just
making tough shots now the offense is
dried up but I'm telling you San Diego
State feels good about where they're at
because they played awful defensively
and they're still in the game they're
only down seven
and you talked about it Robbie they've
been down a lot of games and have come
back and and won that's just a sign of
experience and being in this situation
so this there's a lot of game left uh
but I think they're gonna have to find
scoring and easy buckets you can't rely
on Matt Bradley Jabs up jab step pull up
yep you're not gonna win they got to get
open shots and it's steals Force
turnovers for layups get to the paint
and get to the foul line I was not
expecting both teams to be shooting over
40 from three but FAU to have those
numbers against the San Diego State team
that we've been talking all day and
really all week is pretty staggering I
mean this is the fourth best defensive
college basketball in terms of
efficiency the physicality that Tyler
talked about early in the show it and
Candace mentioned this you cannot
prepare for that you can watch film you
can talk about it until you're blue in
the face but it's that ball gets thrown
up and you got hands on you and you got
physical bodies on Anya and some of the
veteran big bodies that San Diego has or
San Diego State has you're you're never
going to be able to feel comfortable but
but give them a lot of credit because
they flipped that physicality and
they've driven those guys they have
lived in the paint yeah and the other
thing is we're not really talking about
is this is a huge Stadium neither team
plays in a stadium like this this is a
football stadium this is something
they're not used to so for these teams
to be shooting like this is a question
mark coming into the final four always
how would they shoot into this big of
Arena the line of sight and all exactly
isn't that drastically different I think
it's a huge difference I'm I'm more of a
small gym guy I grew up in small gyms I
like kind of you know everything right
there when you get in these huge Arenas
sometimes it can mess with you uh so I
was very curious to see how either team
especially because their Arenas aren't
that big mid Majors how they would shoot
in one of these huge domes I will say
they've done a better job the floor is
now in the middle of the field back what
was it when we were playing it wasn't
all of them but I played in a game in
Glendale Arizona at the Cardinal Stadium
we've lost to UConn the team that you oh
no Michigan State got them before you
played them in the final four we the
court was in the end zone They had
temporary bleachers so there'd be like
20 rows that they'd bring in yeah and
then you've got a hundred and well 100
yards of field and then however far the
bleachers go back into that end zone of
just dead space
shoot up as a shooter just because of
and it was so weird but now at least
you're in the middle so that you're
you're not seeing one end one corner
because some of the corner threes you'd
shoot you'd be looking at like 150 yards
wow before you saw the action is that
what it's like at Syracuse with the
Carrier Dome yeah I've never played
there I've never played there
they have the temporary bleachers yeah
do you remember your first did you have
any shots in like the final four where
you were like what the hell was that
well luckily big man uh was kind of
around the rim so
no not none for me I mean luckily the
practice prepares you for it uh and also
North Carolina uh the Smith Center is
one of the biggest Arenas in college so
that kind of helped prepare me as well
uh
Big Kenny wrote learning Tyler
Hansbrough is afraid of owls was not on
my bingo card today
I don't think you're afraid of Allison
he respects them I I didn't like how
people were just kind of not giving
hours of respect they deserve because
they are territorial animal and if
anybody's been around the house you
don't mess with owls do you read outdoor
magazine
do you uh no do you hunt no okay but she
seems like you have an understanding is
this okay for you
[Laughter]
you're right we did kind of poo poo owls
but owls are uh they're a hot you showed
a lot of respect to the ass I wouldn't
mess with an owl I mean Aztecs I mean
I'm not messing with them now
um
uh let's see
3D RF what does UNC need to do to get
back to a tournament team
I think
um
I think it comes down to chemistry I
think the guy's got to be chemistry has
to be better and I think it has to I
think that it has to be important for
the team you know for guys not to score
they have to do other areas that impact
the game I think you got to have guys
that you know you know don't put so much
emphasis on scoring the ball or have
explosive scoring nights and I think it
can take a whole team effort but also I
think they've got to have some outside
shooting this year to really help with a
different roster do you think Huber
Davis will look more to utilize the
bench we kind of talked about this on
the way over on our drive and it was so
heavy with that group of five and they
rode that group of five to the national
championship game yeah do you think that
that is maybe a change in philosophy or
does it depend on personnel
no I think uh you know being a first
year head coach I think and also you
know Hubert's kind of a newer coach I
think he's learning too and he's doing a
much better job I think that yeah I
think he will have to use the bench a
little bit more uh you know instead of
rely such a heavy low load on the
starters
uh Tyler potato 213 asks who is your
favorite North Carolina teammates
Bobby Frazier roommate best friend uh
and then he says follow-up least
favorite UNC team no he didn't ask that
I just made that up
you weren't gonna do that
but you might no no how about how about
for you guys
least favorite guy it's a respect thing
but the least favorite guy to go up
against when you were in college the one
that you were like oh this is going to
be exhausting
I mean I honestly Evan Turner I hate to
say that he's my roommate in Belgrade
for the world University games we played
for Bo Ryan so there were some Big Ten
you know yeah chemistry there but he is
the biggest trash talker in the world
really he just unfortunately we had this
game at Purdue where I had a really good
first half I ended up with 35 points but
he ended up with 32 and they won and he
dunked on me in the game and I he all
every time I see him he always brings up
and you know what I think my record was
a winning record against it I think I
got it by one game but he talks more
trash than anybody but you know what
that dude could back it up he was the
national player of the year that season
our junior year and he had an incredible
college career and a very good NBA
career how about you well we saw
Grievous Vasquez in the hallway he
played at Maryland and he always used to
line us up and he would let you know
about it too heavy personality he was a
tough guy to go against but then there
was this other guy named ever Booker
from Clemson oh wow absolutely a beast
he was strong yeah and he would just
beat you up and I knew it was going to
be a physical battle I enjoyed it but I
knew what I was getting into before we
played each other I love playing against
Trevor he was a heck of a competitor
Trevor Booker was on that USA team with
Bo Ryan too he had one of the best dunks
I've ever seen this dude went up with
him he buried him in the floor wow
talked it back I mean Trevor was super
powerful athletic would you put jumper
when Evan Turner would talk trashed do
you talk back or do you just I would
talk back but he was always even in
Serbia where our room was in this we
were in these flats that were unfinished
they were supposed to get done for the
world University games they didn't get
finished so it was me Evan Turner and
Deshawn Butler from West Virginia oh wow
in three twin beds there was no
furniture except we each had a dresser
in the living room and then it was
Jarvis Fernando from Mississippi State
and Craig bracken's in the actual bed
room then there was a couple more rooms
to the rest of the guys in our team and
he would just we we all three of us we'd
played West Virginia so Ohio State saw
West Virginia Purdue saw West Virginia
Purdue played Ohio State and Evan would
just out of nowhere be like man Deshawn
you guys cheated in Morgantown just like
annoying stuff like that like just
always I didn't know when the game's not
going on what's that he's trash talking
years after the game even the next year
they because Ohio State went to
Morgantown and beat those guys yeah and
he was talking about it eight months
after the fact I mean he'd talk on the
court he'd talk off the court he'll send
me he'll send me a text still and
they'll be like yeah we whooped you back
in the day like stuff like that I don't
see you as a trash talker but I would I
could imagine you yelling and maybe an
opposition would be near you and they
would feel that you weren't talking
trash were you rarely I mean if I was I
was never a big trash talker you
probably Robbie was not you're not a
trash talker either you weren't you
didn't talk a lot of trash so uh no it
was uh it's a little more physical if I
got upset it was not like in a dirty you
were chest to chest
uh if I was talking smack it was more uh
I had got hit or something that happened
ah
all right I was a trash talker but I
didn't have to back it up because I was
usually seventh eighth man so you were
chirping From the Bench I'll just say
this those guys oh there was one time I
got in against our arrival team and we
it was like the game was in hand and I
got a technical foul in the 20 seconds
that I was out there I went on my boxing
dude shot the ball came into my hand and
then I chest pass it to him and the
coach is like I just put you in and I
was like bro I got on the sheet I got
the teeth that's right oh I had to or
the stat
all right we got a tweet as we get ready
look at this one from Brian Fisher FAU
is a remarkable
27-1 this season when leading at
halftime but the Silver Lining is San
Diego State is seven and two when
trailing at the break I think there's a
few things incredible about that FAU
27-1 so like 95 of their games they've
been leading at halftimes I mean they've
had an amazing year you don't have an
amazing year and win 35 games right like
that's an incredible statistic in itself
to be on the back half of they win the
night they'll be you know over the
halfway mark to four today does Bradley
come out
in the second half you take Bradley out
I don't think you deviate from what you
are but if you get down you need to roll
with your best guys
you guys played nearly 40 minutes yeah
yeah like you just didn't come out yeah
there was games you go to overtime you'd
see guys play oh yeah but I mean like
regulation oh no totally San Diego
State's also a deeper team yeah they
used their bench a lot yeah it's their
identity yeah so they use their bench
but also you know when you're in the
tournament some coaches like to shorten
their rotations and then we'll rely you
know more on the starting five and also
I'm under the impression if if a guy's
having a career night totally agree let
him ride him some some you know I don't
care if he's a bench player who he is if
he's going off leave him out there yeah
yeah yeah all right we'll see if Bradley
can turn it back on 11-3s combined
between the two teams uh FAU shooting
over 50 percent from the floor in the
first which is insane when you factor
all of this void 60 from three and
Bradley doing it well as well uh we we
have ourselves uh a superstar joining us
uh right now he was just named today the
Bob the award winner as the best point
guard in college this is a guy that in a
college basketball game this year that
we all loved 20 points 19 assists it is
Marquis Noah let's go give it up for him
first of all congratulations Bob Cousy
point guard of the Year appreciate it
how does that sound how does it make you
feel I mean it feels good I mean to say
that to the best point guard in college
basketball I mean it's humbling man I
gotta give all the honest all the glory
to God
this uh last few weeks for you man man
how do you describe it
surreal it's been it's been fun though
it's been exciting
um I mean all my hard work and all my
dedication you know over the years is
paying off and to see it unfold in front
of my eyes have you had a chance to like
watch the highlights
yeah a couple of times I I rewinded it a
couple times I mean because this game
was freaking nuts man and you're from
New York and you're in the garden yeah
where are you from in New York Harlem
Manhattan what what uh east side
window knife in Lexington 109 for the
Lex okay yeah you know your stuff I've
been in there for a decade man okay okay
so I mean had you gone and seen games in
the garden growing up yes uh I actually
went to go see Kyrie Kyrie gave me some
tickets one day really go watch him play
when he was on the Cleveland Cavaliers
and then I watched um the Knicks play on
Christmas day which is my birthday
um Iman Shumpert yeah yeah J.R Smith
turned it up that day so is that your
first time playing in the garden though
or you played there before that was my
first time did it live up to the hype
yeah it was everything else when it's
going oh there's no better place to play
than imagine Square guard can you
explain why well and from an MBA
standpoint you have the celebrities
there so like we'd play a game you might
see Magic Johnson Spike Lee's there
right SNL is there John Mcenroe's there
yeah but just the the feel the history
of it the way the crowd's into it is it
even like the tunnels and everything
yeah totally you know the history of
that building I played there in college
in the priest at nit against Oklahoma
and Blake Griffin was on the Oklahoma
team so it was a big game both teams
were ranked and there was only probably
5 000 people there was like man the
garden it's not all of traffic yeah
played an NBA game there it was a
weekend both teams were having a good
start to their seasons and I was like
man there is no place I'd rather play
than mad Square Garden it's amazing yeah
I agree all right I want to see some of
the tweets from during your performances
that people were putting out there
because you captivated everybody with
how you were playing uh Marcus Noel
ladies and gentlemen don't stop Trey
young that's my guy he's he's been
texting me uh every every day before the
game and telling me to keep going and
don't stop well if there's one guy that
did it up in New York City it was Trey
young as he was tormenting the Knicks uh
what other tweets do we got here I mean
shoot Trey that was unbelievable KD that
was a legendary display of controlling a
basketball game
I was legendary that's that's that's
crazy to see I mean you know KD is is
one of the goats I mean you just it's
humbling to see that you know he he
admires and then you got Magic Johnson
who tweeted uh I feel like he used chat
gbt to congratulate you congratulations
to Kansas State basketball yeah uh can I
I want to clear something up just for my
own stuff I feel like you've talked
about it the chiante Johnson alley-oop
that's for y'all to find out I can't
tell you I thought here it is right here
I thought it was acting I thought you I
think that you should be up for best
actor I mean that's that's some hell of
an acting right there
I think
[Laughter]
I think goes like like this is your cue
to throw it that's my guess but uh
Marquis man you've been the to me oh
good catch right there
that finger up yeah you got some
Geniuses because I
[Applause]
um
I don't know I mean saving it for the
book
If coach tank pull it out again
what's it like playing for Coach tank
and is he that good of a dancer good of
a dancer I mean everything I mean he's a
one of one I mean he's a coach that you
really want to play for uh he loves his
kids he shows you know all his players
that he cares about them
um and he just lets you have freedom I
mean you don't have to hide anything you
don't have to be somebody that you're
not I mean you could just go out there
and be yourself I mean he's going to
love you for that where'd the whole
little baby thing come from how did that
get started I made it just a locker room
thing that we did uh in the beginning of
the Season uh naquan and chiante started
it up with the clap but it was a
different song uh before the little baby
one on the little baby one just blew up
oh uh so we started off this half
already two threes FAU hit one San Diego
State hit one this is a San Diego State
team that we've seen shut everybody down
and then FAU now has eight threes you
went up against him yeah can you break
down this game for us what are you
seeing so far so for FAU they love the
three-point line I mean they have you
know great guards that could get into
the paint and facilitate and get to the
three-point line so that's going to be
San Diego's you know big key to if you
could limit them to 10 or less threes
um and for San Diego State I feel like
they got to power the ball inside
because they have the the bigger guys
and they're more stronger and you know
more physical so it's gonna be a battle
it's gonna be a 40 minute game it's
gonna be a lot of highs a lot of lows so
you just gotta grind it out I'm not
gonna lie I was thinking about you going
up against San Diego State and what that
would have been like I feel like you
would have been making people touch
Earth I don't think they would have seen
that kind of speed before man as uh to
be here all right well San Diego State
has cut the deficit to five FAU
they knocked down one triple
it's starting to get spicy yeah oil
pressure is going to be key oh they got
to contain that bounce they didn't do a
good job in the first half keeping the
dribble oh there you go
block three right there and now there's
11 seconds on the shot clock so now it's
ATO time
okay probably gonna run a flare
slip screen flare something like that
all right FAU one for seven in the
second half already but they've gotten a
number they've got three offensive
rebounds a good d by the big wow I reach
down oh man
they're switching too there was one
second left on the shot clock SDSU
commits the foul at the end that's tough
Tyler what was it like watching this guy
ball out against Michigan State
Marquis was my favorite player to watch
all year I've already mentioned that uh
in most people he's been doing it all
year a lot of people just saw it during
the tournament he's had a great run all
year and Marquis my question
he came you went in the portal how did
you know Tang was going to be such a
good fit and why was this year you know
like kind of like I would say I'm just
now knowing about you if I would have
known you were this good I've been
watching you for years man uh the portal
I feel like it's a good situation for
most people if you use it the right way
I mean I just knew K-State was a perfect
fit and when I got there the culture was
so good so you know when when there was
a coach uh coaching change
um I just believed in a culture and I
wanted to stay faithful to K-State and
you know what they embody and it didn't
matter who was coming in but with Coach
tank coming in it was like an icing on a
cake man he he established that he
wanted to win right away he didn't want
to rebuild and that was music to my ears
how long did it take you to realize all
right even though Bruce Weber's he's
moving on and we've got drone tank
coming in I want to stay here and I want
to stay in Manhattan I mean as soon as
the season ended in March I mean I knew
I wanted to stay uh I'm a guy that I to
stick things out through adversity it
doesn't matter you know I mean you you
went you were in control of your own
destiny um and that's how I live my life
and you know I just put my head down I
work as hard as I can and I keep my
faith in God
did I hear you declared yeah so now how
does this process work I got my agent
here with me I got my brother here with
me but um you know we just you do the
workouts you see kind of what they say
yeah then you make the decision from
there yeah uh it's exciting bro yeah
it's it's a blessing to even be you know
in a talk of you know being in a draft
and you know working out in front of
teams yeah yeah I mean shoot I'd say go
to the next but Jalen brunt that's kind
of doing your thing right now he cooking
over there too much taxes see what he
had
that's that's spoken like a man that
knows his business right there too many
times I live right there I know exactly
half uh Trammell is making a running
eight hour but now I need these guys at
San Diego State to to pull ahead and
take a lead but Trammell has been good
here over the last two minutes five
points in the second half Florida
Atlanta course hit uh another three so
that's nine for the game game San Diego
State now down seven
okay do you think like when people come
and they talked about college basketball
and they make their predictions you see
it at such a different level than they
do yeah when you looked at these four
teams what did you think of Uconn Miami
and these two teams who did you think
was going to win before anything started
uh I mean obviously I thought K-State
was going to win when we first started
March but you know I like UConn chances
I mean they they have a big man they
have great guards we get downhill and
make plays for others and they have a
great coach wow I mean yeah I mean the
hurleys are known for winning I mean
that's that's the Saint Anthony's you
know what I mean I went to St Anthony's
my uh freshman year of high school
really yeah play with uh Bob Hurley told
me some amazing things you played Four
coach early yeah really wow what do you
remember from Matt man he was intense I
mean he wanted he wanted to win and I I
enjoyed it even though I was on a bench
I was learning you know so much from him
um I try to grasp as much as I can from
him I mean but he wanted to win
everything was detailed
um on on how to win and we did that year
we won what age did you decide I want to
be great and how did that how did that
process start for you uh well me and my
brother had this talk in a room one day
shout out to Marcus died to my brother
he asked me what I wanted to be growing
up around seven years old and I told him
I wanted to be an NBA player and he told
me that he was going to do everything in
his power to make sure that I'm an NBA
player so I mean we've just been on the
ground ever since give me like the
details so like what time are you waking
up like how crazy did you go I went
crazy every day I mean I worked out
there was times where I'd be in the gym
from 12 P.M to 12 a.m just shooting from
the logo making 25 a spot yeah I mean
literally no joke I mean we we put in a
lot of hours you know for an opportunity
like this and you know we used to walk
around New York City go to different
parks and just shoot on different parts
to get the field of different rims yeah
and stuff like that and that's how you
know my jump shot got so last year
so it was just it was just a grind and I
embraced it and I loved it because I
knew that you know I was getting better
yeah isn't it great when like a young
guy gets it yeah I mean because I know
you all did the same thing but the work
in yeah things will happen yeah I want
to ask you about New York City point
guards there's always so much hype but
also so much ability yeah why is New
York so known for putting out guys that
just can score it but also run the team
have a flare and do that too yes it's
just a style of play I mean just growing
up playing in those Parks I mean you see
all different kind of players you see
flashy players look at you know Kenny
Smith Mark Jackson uh you got Kenny
Anderson you got all these type of point
guards who play different Marbury
Stephon Marbury
so you know that's just how we grew up
playing I mean and we bring that type of
you know playing style to wherever we go
I mean we are fearless we want to win
and you know we show that
awesome do you think the Rams on the
park are tougher to shoot on and harder
than the rims out here at the final four
I would say the Rams in the park don't
give yeah they don't get people don't
understand how hard the rims can be do
you see a double Rim yeah definitely
you're dunking on those things either
tearing your hands up and they might be
tilted a little yeah depending on where
you're playing at if people have been
dunking on them too much right yeah all
right so what would be your advice uh to
both teams right now after watching the
the first 25 minutes uh
so like if you were in the Huddle what
are you saying I'm saying we gotta put
put together some stops uh when we when
I was at K-State we would say kills so
that's three stops in a row
um that's a kill so we gotta put a
couple of those
um into play and then you know just keep
making the right play making a simple
play and making it tough you need with
these type of teams you need ball
pressure I mean you need to create Havoc
so the ball can't move side to side
I mean that's what you were saying
earlier Tyler FAU is having too much
free range of motion being able to kind
of Drive the lane wherever they want
what's that surprising but the way that
San Diego and and what they've been all
year that's a surprising thing to see
especially for a veteran team who has
you know their average age I say again
it's 23. they should know the rotations
and when to help so it is a little
glaring for a team like San Diego San
Diego State with all this experience uh
just to not be doing that right now but
also just the straight line drives I
mean they're just whipping them off the
bounce yeah there's the D I'm telling
you the boss in his hands it is going up
I feel like FAU has a lot of kills
tonight yeah they do they do it they're
making uh Sandy FAU making San Diego
State take the shot that they want I
don't think San Diego State is taking a
shot that they want right we do have
some tweets coming in as well
we'll show them as we continue to watch
this game
oh this is from you 20 points 19 assists
a record I think that says five steals
yeah you ever got 20 assists in the game
or is 19 your your career high College
High School everything I mean the most I
ever got you know prior to 19 was 17.
I mean I'm gonna try to get 20 one day
and see how that feels what was the 17
game uh that was back in high school and
Bishop Locklin I had 17 assists but 20
would be special have you had a chance
to go back to New York after yet no I
mean go there in the Summers no I
actually haven't been in New York in
three years prior to play in the MSG
stay in it gotcha I've been staying at
school just working out grinding oh man
you got to take the trip back summer New
York what do you think that's going to
be like to go back and now you've had
this King of New York stuff man it would
be a blessing it'll be humbling I mean
it's it's gonna be nothing but love Best
Slice yeah where is it the best slice
oh so you could go anywhere really okay
best chopped cheese oh uh 100 knife in
Lexington 109th in Lexington yeah okay
all right now I want to now see a buddy
cop show of Marquis and Tyler
hansborough going to New York uh and
just playing 2-0 he could be like the
Billy Hoe from uh uh white man can't
jump and he pretends like he can't play
but you call him in from the rafters I
definitely get 20 assists
playing on the concrete right now yeah
that'd be done that sounds Tough All
right so what happened here fau's
claiming they got hit after the play
there was an elbow to the ribs I thought
it should have been out of bounds it
looked like when that FAU player put it
down that ball hit hit the Baseline did
you see if there was any kind of see the
after play so I hope they show it again
I'm with Robbie it was out yeah and I
didn't see the elbow even though I was
looking for it here we go you know we're
taking a look at it we're going to show
it to you guys
that looks a little acting I hope they
don't give him a t for that this will be
a better angle right here
here it is
you wanna hear one of my left coat takes
yes if you act and then we have to sit
through all of this you should get a
foul for doing the acting and then doing
this whole thing I think there is a
tentacle for flopping College I think
this is yeah there is there is but I
think this is going to be just because
of the way the rules are set up a dead
ball technical foul you really think
there's going to be I'm not saying it
should be no no no no I think because of
the way the rules are set up I would be
surprised with the Way That Elbow goes
if they don't bang him with it yeah John
Higgins is not going to play that that's
yeah that's true I do not want to see a
technical here I don't even I agree
there should be a technical and I think
it'd be kind of somewhat deciding the
game I don't care it shouldn't be a
technical in this situation this is
nothing is that the name of the ref yeah
you know you know all the refs names
most of them I mean he's pretty heavy in
the big 12.
because that's like an NBA a vet move is
knowing all the refs names and all that
stuff but in the NBA a lot of times and
I'm sure Tyler's seen this you'll see
some of the coaches they'll put tape on
the floor and they'll start writing down
the names of the right really just to
remember just to remember yep yeah
[Applause]
yes I have questions for you in the chat
so I'm gonna pull them up
all right
as this updates Lord nutmeg says Mr New
York City favorite NBA player who you
got oh my Stephen Curry
number one yeah I like that who's second
to step or who was it growing up who was
it growing up uh it was Kemba Walker
yeah
he's gonna be here later he is have you
met Kemba yet no well I met him I spoke
to him on Facebook oh you did yeah okay
yeah okay big Kenny Marquis who is the
craziest person who reached out to you
so they gave him the T yeah I hate that
call I do too I don't like it
no you don't call it sorry yeah because
you could have just said your elbow went
back all right walked up on him too uh
Marquis the craziest person who reached
out to you during the tournament run
oh
and let's not do Twitter let's do like
FaceTime or somehow got your number or
something uh
uh I say
Trey young probably sorry how did it
happen did you just get a phone call and
you picked it up well Trey young uh well
coach Perry is uh Trey Young's you know
Au coach so that connection was there
and he was ruined for us you know in
March Madness yeah yeah he showed some
love I have a question from the back and
these might be before your time oh man
mace or Cam'ron
I mean it's
I mean it's bigger than just music too I
get it I get it sorry
the plan but I could just see camera
like at your high school game yeah cam
oh he could ball too yeah he was he was
a Hooper he's a Hooper Hooper
all right with the technical and all the
free throws that have come with it this
has gone from a nine point FAU lead to a
13-point FAU lead and this is what Tyler
was saying you don't want something like
that decided in this game
I I don't think it's right now it
wouldn't decide the game but I just
don't like it because the momentum has
shifted drastically in San Diego State's
trying to fight their way back I don't
like it either way I just don't think
it's I think it's a no call but coach is
always talking about how you can't
compound your mistakes okay they call
the technical foul but then you file a
three-point shooter right yeah I don't
like the call either I think with the
way the rules are written that it was
going to get called but man that's a
five-point possession on simply foul
shots it's just a killer you can't have
that San Diego State answers a little
teardrop in the lane
cutting the deficit to 12 as you're
seeing it now but FAU in full control
yeah
what do you think of Elijah Martin
the tank isn't out there for for FAU
that's number 15. uh yes yes yeah I like
his game he's
he's
a really really good player
oh I have another question
did you think about pulling that shot at
the end I thought about it but I seen
three what was the play the play was
gonna be like a handoff do you get it
back now to play with to set a a screen
for me a half court so I can come down
here and shoot but and what happened
there was three players so I was coming
up my teammate set the screen and there
was three players around him hanging
yeah
so oh dude I I was like he's gonna pull
it from half I said that oh I never
turned down a game winning well now you
never will again never ever yeah
we have whistles here racing down for
the San Diego State fans yeah the
whistles are starting to
kind of impact the game you could say
the Tide's gonna turn I mean they've
only called one foul in Florida Atlantic
this whole half and San Diego State's
got seven usually in college they try to
get that that number uh somewhat close
to each other so I expect a few calls
for uh San Diego State to come that
12-minute timeout could not come quick
enough they need that immediately San
Diego State to turn this around
do you have something Robbie
oh for for what yeah for uh Mr Marquis
Choco Taco says what are you guys
thinking about fouling when up
I'm for it are you yes it depends on the
situation
I'm with Marquis I usually don't like
the fact I like to have defensive
principles and you trust your defense
some situations I might do it but nah I
mean Tom izzo's he's on that side too
that Michigan State doesn't ever foul
really three I just think
you're taking away you're making it
really tough now we've seen teams kind
of counter this by you'll see teams
throw a baseball pass into the front
Court call time out now it's harder but
if they're bringing the ball up I'm for
it
all right San Diego State down 14
hoisted up at three get it to fall cut
the deficit to 11.
a really good shot like Robbie was
saying that was contested that was a
little bit of a jab so that wasn't out
of the flow of the offense either
they're gonna have to get some better
looks against your buckets in that
that's a big shot for him though Parish
has really struggled two of his last 11
from three last couple games
can't reach in the words of Marquis
Aztecs need a Kill
they got one stop last time don't foul
don't foul good defense wide open
doesn't hit it we're going the other way
now they got to push it there we go push
it they do
and then they pull it back out
listen to Marquis he knows what he's
doing
I gotta get some movement there we go a
little bit of movement FAU on it
somebody got a cut they're all just
standing around yeah somebody gotta cut
there's one of the handsboro Falcons
hands on them and the San Diego State
fans are ironically cheering
hey you're right none of the San Diego
State threes have been easy they're all
individual great plays like it's jab jab
Pole
it's not like the threes we're seeing
Florida Atlantic get where it's like
they are driving it two feet in the
paint spraying it
you can tell that the difference in
shock quality is is definitely large and
Matt Bradley's back on the court he
immediately touches the Rock and he gets
fouled on a three almost knocked it down
so Tyler what else do you want he said
this was coming if you watch college
Robin you knew this yeah you knew if the
the fowzers that big of a difference
they're going to give some bunnies to
the other team yeah I mean I don't even
like that shot selection right there a
pump fake for a three yeah uh I do like
that Matt Bradley's back in he's got 11
points and I liked how that play call
was a double screen for Bradley to get
him the ball set him up to possibly do
something and he just came in the game
right to a corner three I'd like to see
him get more of a rhythm but now he gets
three free throws to get into a rhythm
there's second highest percentage shot
in basketball free throw the foul line
behind the dunk
uncontested layup I'm gonna test the
layup
have you dunked
can you dunk
I mean yeah I can done yes
I don't know about that oh bro I'm heavy
you at least are springing you gotta
step on it
I could beat Shaq in a Three-Point
Contest that's about all that's my
athletic claim to fame is that proven
you guys oh yeah I smoked them all right
you heard that check
checks all arms
he's just ah he's throwing darts cats in
it up there all right so now with those
free throws the lead has been cut to
eight
I will say Riley's Breaking the Set when
we turn around and look and a turnover
for FAU the it's filled in here the
crowd was a little light yes early but
it's they want to see a good game and
Miami and UConn's starting to fill in as
well
all right eight points they get the ball
back this is the Marquis Noel effect is
it nolar Noel Noel Noel
movement here it is I like that I don't
like that I like that shot say that one
more time
okay
oh I feel like the San Diego State's
defense is picking up too yeah they they
have picked it up but then there's been
the lulls of not guarding the ball you
know they've had like moments where they
look better in the second half and then
they have the lows where they can't
contain the bounce at all
they're also not going to call those
those cheap fouls on them because of the
difference and I hate to say that bring
that up but right now yeah the momentum
is coming back to San Diego State
because they're making it physical and
kind of an uglier game oh boy as a walk
that's a good move
back to 10 points FAU getting the basket
in the lane I need a good shot right
here
a little pump fake
their pace is just not you know where it
needs to be at do you think seriously
needs to push it yeah I feel like they
need to play faster this is going up
going inside back out
oh
Bradley passes it up that's a good shot
that is a good look that's some dribble
drive and then just spray it
now they need to stop man I was not
expecting this many threes from these
two teams
San Diego State in the midst of a 9-2
scoring run just over the last two
minutes FAU there's a little foul
and that's going to be the 12-minute
timeout as they played Dwyane Wade's rap
song
which should never be played in Arena no
offense but maybe it's because he just
got elected to the Hall of Fame Wendy
record this is it this was like during
pandemic he recorded a rap song with
like
I think Rick Ross
oh all right my my only story before you
go is so I hosted the Tuesday show with
Dwayne for three years but we met during
the Super Bowl when it was Niners Chiefs
and after the game they were like we're
gonna Premiere our rap song that we did
and I was like oh man so they're doing
it and Dwayne comes on and then Rick
Ross starts rapping and Udonis is Udonis
Haslam is in the video the whole time
and I'm standing next to you Donna's
like you're right here and you know if
you see a rap video like if you're up
there like you're gonna rap and I go oh
I can't wait for you to kill it and then
the video ends and he never raps and he
does looked at me and I was like
my bad bro like I was about to Hype him
up but he never even wrapped and I was
like all right man I'm sorry you Donna's
hassle
um Marquis from all three of us it was a
pleasure watching you work this year
thank you your mindset your skill it all
came together everyone in here knows
you're a bad man thank you and the
streets of New York know it too whatever
the future holds we're proud of you we
can't wait to see it my man we're
rooting for you thank you thank you for
having me get up that chopped cheese on
104. man I got you I'm gonna bring three
for it
all right FAU up seven over San Diego
State 11-11 left
Martin with
17. Bradley's up to 14 he had the three
free throws after scoring all those 11
in the beginning
what other stats you got for us
[Music]
well second half
tremel has five yeah certainly he
finally got it going Micah parash who
had been struggling has six he's made
both the threes he's attempted and
honestly for Florida Atlanta it's been
all about Elijah Martin he's got ten oh
they're 18 points he has been in the
second half massive fact he's got 17 on
the game but 10 of those coming here
after halftime
and what are the teams shooting from
three overall on the game Florida
Atlantic shooting 44 8 of 18 from three
San Diego State's eight of 15. wow 53
from three they're three of four in the
second half Florida Atlantics two of
four in the second half so the shots
from the from the perimeter are going
down
Tyler you were able to predict that that
little run there of of referee Ticky
tack fouls I could tell you watch a lot
of college hoops this 11-minute mark
down to like the five minute Mark what
is this stretch like
we always like to talk about the end of
halfs in the beginning of house but
we'll let this Middle Run
for me I think San Diego State just has
to get it close I think they have to get
it within three to kind of keep it there
because either way uh you know I've said
San Diego State's experienced team
they've come from behind a lot yeah in a
lot of these games uh I think for them
they got to get it a little bit closer
and they've got to have momentum going
their way if you're talking about FAU I
think they've got to get Darnell Davis
involved a little bit he's their leading
scorer I know Elijah Martin's having a
big game but they're going to have to
have somebody else help him yeah you
predicted a low scoring game for Janelle
he did
yeah that one I also predicted uh
Florida Atlantic under 65. yeah under 65
points I'm not sure that's going to
happen gotta get some stuff I predicted
over two and a half Dives and I don't
know if we've seen one I don't know if
we have I thought that that was a
terrible number you thought it was
really low but I I think I have to give
you credit I don't think we've seen one
that's my favorite camera angle by the
way okay here's our locks my favorite
camera angle if we can show it is when
there's like the little camera that's
along the floor
it's like the 100 meter dash cam yeah or
like we're seeing like greyhound racing
there it is that camera angle is the
best well I don't like that shot that's
awful shot mid-range contestant off the
dribble they just don't generate quality
looks they just they don't move the ball
it's a lot of standing around oh
wow
Florida Atlanta already in the bonus
and the fouls keep coming one foul away
from double bonus which is gonna be a
big deal oh talking about 10 minutes
left in the game
you're right team's ninth
golden to the quiet game for as well as
he played against Kansas State he's got
Tyler when you were in the final four
were you the first gamer of the second
game
do you remember
um
I'm gonna guess you're the second game
because I feel like they'd Save North
Carolina for the late game the ratings
I can't remember actually so I was in
the final four twice but I think the oh
boy
it's a big bucket
[Applause]
Bradley now with 17 five of nine from
the floor
they lobbing in the big man and we are
going the other way
that's great defense from Bradley too
who's at it he's a smaller guy guarding
a 7-1 Defender but he is a heck of a
shot right here that is
sometimes they just feel it man
those lefties too they look different
when they're casting that thing up there
man it spins differently it just looks
it's a pretty jumper
there's a let's go Aztecs chant building
this feels like the most momentum
they've had in a while
Bradley is begging for it I'm just
letting him make plays
I think the big needs to set a screen
for Bradley to get a mismatch or even
get to the handoff stuff get him to his
left hand
five seconds on the shot clock they're
going into your guy ladies bang that was
a beautiful move though he gets to that
right hand he's tough to stop down the
spin because he won't get a shoot with
his left got back to that right
quick FAU shot with set they only took
seven seconds off the shot clock 28 were
on Now Bradley's got it and they cut
they know foul
step back pump fake step back pump fake
to the Lane
[Applause]
what if Tyler I felt that fist pump
Tyler fist bumped and I stood up because
I felt his energy
wow man that usually could have been an
ant one I'm sure that's how did he die
he's walking to the foul line and you're
gonna compose yourself but those are the
ones where you're like man I I should
have had that one I touched all of it
but they've they've chipped away they've
got it if he makes these two it's a it's
a two-point game which is where they
want to be and you can feel the momentum
shift I I think they're they're going to
get some bunnies coming up because of
the foul discrepancy too so it's gonna
be interesting to see where this game is
here in three minutes
I literally asked Tyler I said with
about five minutes left where does it
need to be and he was like two to three
and we're at we're getting there Tyler
you're you got a big brain over there
you can predict the future and I might
need to watch games with you during the
year so I can just Tyler what do I bet
on okay good listen my absolute locks
yeah I've been awful this year I put
them on Twitter I'm like three for 15.
really so this is just happens to be a
rare that's funny because I think they
have some of them that we could Showcase
of the absolute Lux how about FAU four
for their last 15 from the field I mean
San Diego State has clamped down
16-4 San Diego State run and way do
y'all see this dunk by FAU wow that'll
get momentum back on your side well you
break the pressure with the drive and
with back Cuts that's a great song it's
with my favorite camera there you go
with the Sprinter cam there's that back
back door cut oh that's pretty and then
FAU gets a stop they're going the other
way
four point game
oh that's what you do with an aggressive
defense so then when they get out in
that passing Lanes the back door Cuts
just wide open that's a great uh cut by
you
tweet selection committee should be
embarrassed for this for making this FAU
team a nine the only thing I'll say we
have seen those smaller teams over the
years with 30 wins come in and we go oh
they can win it Down Right wow there's
your guy again
he loves that ride
he's a big body though I always he
didn't get much of an opportunity to
Ohio State but he's making the most of
it here as an Aztec if I'm fau's coach I
call a timeout right now you guys need
to get a good bucket instead wow and
that's why you don't call him
what a shot instead you just let him
come off the screen and knock down a
triple and I think that's 20 points for
him in this game Elijah Martin is a
beast yes he is
17 in the second half he has 24 Martin
ladies shooting it again
I'd like to know percentage of touches
that turn into shots FAU can't get it
Taps the rebound we're going the other
way the highest usage player in the
country
we are under eight minute timeout you
see it there Elijah Martin 24 and five
clearly the player of the game thus far
and still I think San Diego State should
feel good about where they are all
things considered the only thing that
I'm really worried about is the double
bonus
and with their physical the last few
minutes I'm concerned with their offense
too I think they've been hitting some
hero shots lately FAU oh no I'm talking
about San Diego State I would like to
see them get some easy uncontested
layups even though you know the bid gets
that right hand hook Bradley has taken
some contested threes and made them I
would like to see them get some easy
buckets literally this entire highlight
package is going to be Bradley shooting
threes the Mis layout that turn the
light to the free throws and then just
the D all the spins to the right hand
there it is that's been that's all it's
been for this entire hat how many times
they made nine threes I can think of one
time where it was dribble penetration
into the paint and kickoff for a three
the rest have just been Square you up
jab head fake Let it Fly yeah and you
got to get the ball inside people think
that's just thrown in the post no it
comes off a penetration as well when you
draw the defense you step right in and
it's just a high percentage look
I'm gonna say that can I tell you what
I'm really nervous about
those free throws off the elbow yeah
playing in a very important role at the
end of this so it's definitely a little
large I would be pretty upset about that
too yeah if it is a one-point game I
think absolutely sitting there and going
that stupid elbow car and here's my
other thing is the player looks at him
tells him to go review it yeah you
should never do that
I'm sure we don't even know he could
have said something you think about guys
baiting dudes into that you get hit hey
review that one yeah and another thing
it does is it encourages players to do
that more often if they're just gonna
call technicals like that for a little
Ticky tack elbows you walk up on
somebody more players are going to do it
FAU right now 14 of 17 from the free
throw line I always look at this if one
team has made more free throws then the
other team has attempted more often than
not they have the lead Florida Atlantic
has made 14 free throws San Diego State
has only attempted 10 free throws both
teams nine threes in the game thus far
but it is Martin Bradley leading the way
all right hey I'm happy this is back to
being a game when it was 14 I was like
we're going to sit here and talk about
nothing bill
this is good
[Applause]
man Marquis what a New Yorker like every
part of his you're tired oh man did you
ever play with any anyone from New York
any New York point guards I played with
Kemba Walker uh when I was with the
Charlotte for a year yeah yeah yeah
unbelievable point guard our
yeah what's that like
uh I don't know I mean he was a tough
nose uh you know hard point guard
um he put a lot of work in too so that's
the one thing I really respect about him
yeah he really worked on his game and
you know when I was with Charlotte he
was the leader how hard is it when
they're so good at dicing up Defenders
to not just sit and watch and also be
like oh I need to set screens or rebound
because sometimes when they're cut all
you the whole arena is just watching
Kemba dancing you know he's a jitterbug
I mean it's uh
you can get caught up in that I mean
just yeah he's he's a special player all
right San Diego State 15 on the shot
clock
[Applause]
they've blown that play up that's good
defense by FAU every
handoffs they finally got one four
seconds left there's gonna have to be a
miracle shot two one go oh wow you know
what that makes up for San Diego State
bailing them out earlier with that later
yeah
yeah you just got to know time and place
on that one
I mean that was such a good defensive
possession yes for 32 seconds every
handoff's contested they're blowing them
up and then they're going for a miracle
shot like you said and you just totally
bail them out
man and golden I think I think Golden's
a freshman so that's that's a young
mistake that's where experience comes
into play
the D barely hitting front rim on that
one
they're now nine of 11. San Diego State
from the free throw line so this guy was
he a big recruit at Ohio State no I
don't feel like he was he might have
been a top 150 kid but he wasn't like a
five-star boy but a rebound for the
Aztecs
immediately outside good look from three
but he passes it up the floater come on
Wow and he gets his own bored but he
falls and they call another foul and now
the fouls are getting even
next foul one and one yeah and the bonus
you got to convert on these you got to
make your free throws a big deal right
over the foot that's your travel Guy
what's he got I think he's still at five
oh God I need tremel to get hot
tremel inbounding outside that looks
like a walk
[Applause]
boy it's just so stagnant there's one
guy going they got a pretty good look
though man he has not hit they've gotten
three offensive rebounds but FAU coming
away with it
this is such a big possession
wow blew it
I'm also going to say
can say are we is this the entire second
unit for San Diego State or is this a
mix
no Lamont Butler's out there ladies
second unit tremel's first is the mix so
is this like giving Bradley the Breather
before the stretch run at the end
we talked about that yeah now he's
sitting I'm with Tyler on this side
all right they just made all their subs
yeah he'll go the rest of the way he has
to he's got to touch the ball every
possession
inside of the big wow come on man
was that a foul I want to see a replay
okay I thought it was looking at it live
yeah
great move Idol Oh I
well hold on where does it all right
right boy they're both really physical
there I don't think it was yeah there
was jockey in for a position yeah it was
a good swim move by the big kid though
it was
vladislav golden
not a good foul shooter this is free
throws
you pick FAU yeah
we got people back here they got FAU
you don't have them in your bracket
though do you
went to FAU oh you can talk
oh the ghost Miss free throws oh all
right oh
wait a second
wow
our possession San Diego State but that
could be big if we get another jump ball
here Lane
so he came and just ripped it
wow he dang that was a quick whistle too
it was I was that was a little too quick
for me
all right down five Aztecs with the ball
we're under six minutes left
Bradley oh
good job dime oh you gotta finish oh
good finish good put back foul on
vladislav and that puts FAU or at San
Diego State into the bonus
that was a great pass by it really was
and a really good cut too that was the
first time where I feel like you guys
have been asking can I get one clean cut
clean and that was it and they didn't
finish the layout that's the buckets
they need they got to convert on them
too
nowaday who just almost airballed the
first to throw missed the second one
[Applause]
hit every part of the rib uh
what can you explain to us
game on the line 20 000 there everyone's
going I can make free throws yeah the
pressure what's in your head my biggest
thing when I went to the foul line late
in the game was I need to get my heart
rate down and that's a very weird thing
to think about but I would always sadly
with the rebound take big breaths and
even you'll see guys untie their shoe
and kind of stuff yeah give themselves
some time re-tie it and then go to
Bradley takes it in you know what
you tell me if I'm crazy he seems like
the only guy on this team right now
that's okay with this moment he's the
only one playing at his pace is that
okay is that effect but he's been their
guy the whole game I mean he made those
shots early and he's making plays late
one on one he just got right by
Weatherspoon and you got ladies I think
if you get him in the post for that
right hand hook you got to set him up
somehow to get good position uh I think
he put him on that block do you want him
to go Middle with the right hands
depends on what he likes if left block
yes middle yeah I would like it I mean
I'm just saying because he hit two of
them yeah right maybe that's right I
think that's more more of a personal
preference type thing yeah where do you
like to be posted where do you want the
basketball I like the untying your shoe
on purpose oh you'll see guys do that
hold on
and it just gives you you know another
10 seconds to kind of catch your breath
and Bradley hits the first second lady
oh what a block but it gets back out to
Bradley so many offensive rebounds for
San Diego State in the last two minutes
down three he could tie with a three
pump fake in the lane tenth he's going
in Bradley a lot of contact no foul
asking for it faux what is he doing and
he throws it away
all right I want Bradley to be the
playmaker here but the ball needs to
move some it's a bad shot it's not yeah
if you want him to be the guy with the
ball in his hands but it's jab jab head
fake jab and then drive dribble dribble
you got to move the ball some
all right what are we calling here Tyler
I think you try to get something out of
the flow of offense right here obviously
I would put Bradley with the ball and I
would get the big I tried to get valade
uh 50 for FAU on him in some capacity
and then have that mismatched with uh
the guard on uh ladies and then Bradley
being guarded by uh golden Bradley in
the corner
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll also say tell me if this is crazy I
feel like FAU is making a lot of very uh
dumb mistakes that they have not been
making all game in the last few minutes
throwing it trying to get it out not
holding onto the ball just kind of a
little lack of Daisy yeah those are the
mistakes where you're like man we need
to just run some clock you know we can't
turn the ball over this is San Diego
State's game get it ugly put you in the
mud see how you play Oh fake hand off oh
my gosh I call the foul
dude that fake handoff is really hard
for those bigs to guard yeah especially
when they're switching it's such a good
they're so worried about the Lamont
Butler coming off man he almost took his
soul that would have been sick he almost
took his soul I don't know do you want a
ball you think that's foul I don't think
so actually no I think it was just
everybody yelling in the ref went oh and
then noise came out of his whistle wait
though the Net's messed up look at it
wow
boy that would have been an incredible
oh man and just like that golden has
four fouls and I think he's picked up
three of them in the last two minutes
I love that his name is Vlada slav okay
he's their third leading scorer he
hasn't had the best game uh and he also
has a lot of size so if he's out I think
even though he's not scoring I think his
presence and size makes a huge
difference for FAU look at this this is
another way to get that heart rate down
somebody's got some blood now you can
also freeze your shooter too with this
type of thing yes
a ropes a 68 free throw shooter you said
this this feels like a San Diego State's
game right now that could obviously
change but right now it feels like their
style of game they're beating them up on
the boards too that's why golden getting
in foul trouble is such a big deal it
seems like ladies is on every offensive
board uh like we talked about so yeah
the momentum would favor San Diego State
but you know we'll see I mean it could
shift with one of these uh FAU threes
they've been making how many offensive
rebounds at San Diego State have in the
second half second because FAU had three
in the first minute so I think it's good
they've got seven seven seven second
half offensive boards unbelievable 10 on
the game
wow
they play like uh South Carolina women
play where it's just like we don't even
care the first shot's good because we're
crashing but at times their best offense
is just getting on the rim yeah all
right a wrap he can hit him all right a
Rope Rope
oh man I fully flipped
how many times
I feel like you started out you're like
I like San Diego I picked FAU I told
everybody FAU and then as soon as they
get another offensive rebound that's
eight
oh
give it back to him
a rope Bradley oh he thought about it
looking back for a row fau's defense
swarming a rope again Baseline floater
got it and we're tied at 65. he averages
four and a half points a game and the
San Diego State section is going nuts
not a great look but it's a great shot
because it went in independent play
oh FAU wow look at finding God oh the
buckets
oh Rosado he averages five and a half
points a game I mean these aren't like
the dudes that are making plays but
those are back-to-backs not the hero we
asked for it's the one that we decided
we did yeah exactly
oh oh
Bradley okay front rim but they get the
FAU comes down with it and they're
running
oh man that's a good contest there they
flew out at Bradley because he had a
pretty good look initially this is final
four live presented by Wendy's you like
frosties you like burgers sit down and
eat back to the game
they didn't tell me to do that I just
felt like the need
it was great all right five seconds left
good
and we're staying
number one thing don't bail him out with
a foul
under four timeout
okay
all right big brain Tyler what are we
thinking
I gotta see how much time is on the shot
clock I haven't I think it was seconds
on the shot clock two seconds three
fourteen left in the game FAU up two
you literally said they need to get it
to two points with four minutes left
that's where we are
the end of the game is uh who the heck
knows at the end of the game but Tyler
how do you see this game playing out in
the final three minutes
I think it's gonna be back and forth I
think what they've done is they're
letting him play a little more physical
right now so this could be a grinded out
game and I like to favor I would favor
San Diego State right now just because
this style is kind of the way they play
but in particular this out of bounds
play is gonna be interesting to me
because you know uh that San Diego State
is going to try to switch every screen
so I'm gonna see if FAU tries to run
something at The Rim or try to get a
mismatch for a little lob close to the
rim with this uh with only two seconds
left on the shot clock
I like I like Elijah Martin down the
stretch with the way he's played Janelle
Davis like Tyler called has not had a
very effective night but Martin has been
the guy you're you're looking to get in
the paint they've beat these guys off
the bounce all night long the help comes
just spray it out they're a great
three-point shooting team but I think
some of the mental errors you talked
about being solid not being overwhelmed
by the moment not trying to make a hero
baseball pass down the floor you've got
to make some of these just simple run
your stuff stick to your Basics and I
think that if you're San Diego State
it's it's Matt Bradley's time and you
get him going to his left hand hopefully
you can get him somehow an open
three-point look because when he's he's
made tough contested ones yeah you could
just get him free for one that can be
the difference in the game here down the
stretch we're squaring it up with
Wendy's these are the two stars thus far
Martin and Bradley combining for 44
points both had success and it seems
like as we get closer to the end they'll
be the ones with the ball in their hands
wait it's interesting though we talked
about how some of those guys that maybe
aren't the the heroes that we we need
but the ones we deserve and you look at
Giancarlo Rosado down the stretch only
averages Five Points a game but he's a
really good isolation big and look for
him down the stretch here he loves to
spin and get this turnaround jumper and
that's the shot that we just saw so if
the ball ends up elsewhere we've seen a
rope make a shot if you've seen Rosado
make a shot those guys can make
one-on-one plays as well
they just showed a kid on the screen
that uh Robbie and I went out to the
court earlier just to feel it and he
looked at me and he goes Adam schefter
wrong Adam and I went no and he goes and
I showed him he goes oh and I was like
yeah he was oh I know and I was like
yeah okay
Adam shifters five one
put some respect On this man's name
right here thank you bro
all right ref is explaining something
they must have put more time back on
four points they did that was 2.3 I
think
that's a big difference too because then
you can catch dribble and make a play
exactly maybe a screen
a lot of motion noise
that's the execution is not good but
that is a really well drawn up Place
screener became the roller yeah well it
was a slow play too they're switching
too so it's an easy slip on the screen
right to the rim and that's what you
were saying because you knew they were
going to be switching
wow that was well well drawn up but not
well executed
yeah Tyler predicted that one too
Tyler's got the crystal balls on he's on
fire today
oh wow
and he missed the layup how about though
getting out of the way he looks like he
wanted to take a charge and then
realized he wasn't going to get it and
just moved and it kind of threw the
timing off
FAU just cannot finish
offensive glass again say it again
I think both teams are having a hard
time finish this game might come down to
who's going to control the boards and
who can get the offensive rebounds for
some easy putbacks speaking of that
Twitter is agreeing with you as we
talked about at San Diego State FAU
better is watching them not rebound
across the I don't even know if I could
do a crusty
I don't even know what it would sound
like
doesn't he have like the real nasally
kind of voice yeah mad crap I'll have to
re-watch I love when you just start
trying to work yourself if I see any
human I'm like I think I could do their
voice
San Diego State
missing the first free throw
man free throws and rebounds boys
they're 10 to 16 from the line in the
second half here they haven't cashed in
on all of them wow
Chief D here comes the San Diego State
run
Chacos Taco which team seems more ready
for the moment I don't know if either
right now
well I think I agree a little push off
but you know on Elijah right there that
stiff Farm
I didn't realize Martin has four fouls
too
FAU Stutter Step
Martin player of the game can't get the
three to fall rebound by vladislav
ripped it away from a rope oh and he
throws it right to San Diego State first
fast break opportunity of the game and
Bradley breaks it but they give him a
foul I'm not sure about that one live I
don't know either that is not a foul
I thought Bradley's gonna pull up and
shoot a three which would have been the
most Steph Curry thing ever but
was there even he'd even touch him wow
oh my god wow this is one of those games
where you like you want to see
the officials have no impact and they've
had a lot
the elbow technical some of these yeah
well I go off too in that situation
comfortable I'm gonna break the iPad
the foul line has not been kind here in
the second half wow so they're 10 of 18
now
or 11 of 18. this is probably the 21 on
the game 10 of 18 in the second half wow
80 free throw shooter this is who you
won on the line too rare Miss
all right San Diego State
cuts it to one
he's these red leather chairs I am
sweating on my pants so if I stand up
you might it might look like I peed
myself I did it
off of the foul wow
you know I thought that Wendy's would be
the only one with some home cooking
moving is it oh there's like a rub play
wow they call it on Boyd
tone NYC this is going to be the longest
two minutes ever it is possible
a lot of feet movement there San Diego
State still trying to run those dribble
handoffs I traveled and they call it
travel
wow
but you got the mismatch you wanted you
got golden on your guard for an easy
penetration
he kind of tripped on that right foot
just kind of got caught up and man
you're right though he he had golden
come on
Die Hard Niners Squad San Diego State's
the only team who can go 20 of 60 from
the field and still win the game all
hustle and heart
FAU behind the back floater and one
doesn't get it to fall
good move though
good action you faked the handoff and
then he's just got the whole area to
play one-on-one and then behind the back
like you said that's an impressive I
will take good balance with the head
fake
it's a good call too yep wow
all right
Janelle Davis
had a triple double I believe in the
round of 32.
was unbelievable right it was uh 29-12
five and five oh that's what it was it
five steals yes unbelievable game and
since then he's been quiet so much
though that Tyler said I'm taking his
unders and thus far it's been big but
maybe he could come alive 13 and a half
he's got seven now eight now eight all
right
not 69 66.
that also means it's 135 so the overhit
I was wrong about that too I had the
other
clear out right inside
that's a good look for him just give him
that whole right side and just let him
go I run that same play the next
possession right back at it if they have
golden on him I run that same play
Gold's a freshman he's not as strong as
Ladish
and I like the fake handoff too just
because you've been running handoffs the
whole time Centennial state loves the
dho
here we are boys
Wendy's presenting final four live a one
point FAU lead they have the ball 69-68
just less than a minute left this is
what we wanted it's not the 14 point
game that was slipping away it is a one
point matchup if you're FAU are you
trying to use the whole shot clock here
or are you trying to get the ball to
your playmaker's hands in the best
position and whatever happens happens I
think you're just you're running your
offense you know you aren't necessarily
saying we have to use the whole clock
yeah we're looking for the best
available shot whether that comes
is that Elijah Martin I think it is
Martin right now now they went to Davis
on that last play and he delivered so
it's like what Tyler said with the uh
Ladi thing do you go back to the well
that's certainly an option he's he's
more than capable I want to hear what
you guys would do what would you guys do
what would you do if you're FAU first
I'm with Robbie on this I think you got
to go to your two leading scorers uh
John L Davis or Elijah Martin I think
you got to get some type of action in
movement uh in particular probably off a
double screen with the last screen being
a big to try to create a mismatch try to
curl them try to get an easy layup if
I'm FIU I like some of the look for the
back cut stuff and then with the back
cut clearing out now whether it's
Janelle Davis or it's Elijah Martin you
have the option for the back cut which
the pressure is going to be there the
physicality is going to be there if it's
not there you're playing one-on-one
you're driving it at halftime for San
Diego State to win by one to three
points you could have gotten plus one
thousands as the final results
now listen FAU still could win this game
but man that looks juicy right now all
right let's say uh FAU misses
you're running the same play again for
San Diego State you're going down to the
D especially if Gold's in the game I
think that's the key I think if Gold's
in the game you go right back to that
play but even if he's not I would have
ladies at that right elbow and then try
to do something where there may be a
dribble hand off or have that guard go
set a screen for the other guard and
maybe slip it towards the basket and
then you have the dies with the iso at
the right block or at the right elbow if
things don't pan out and I promise you
Brian Dutcher is telling these guys from
this time out right now go to the
offensive glass we've lived there yes
they cannot keep us off the glass they
can't box us out yeah make our way to it
and make our presence fell on the boards
San Diego State has made one of its last
10 field goal attempts eight free throws
in the second half how are they still in
it
man how about the defense though they
were at 60. we were talking about your
number four that was it like
16. yeah 14. and they're only they've
only scored nine points wow
man FAU does not have a field goal the
last 307.
cheese
oh and you know the other thing I just
realized if there is a critical jump
ball they have not had a jump ball since
that one before that was a quick whistle
and that stupid elbow that that elbow
looms large right now with a one-point
game
John L
it's the John L show but now it's Martin
oh
Oh What A Move what a move but it was
exactly what Tyler said it was Davis's
turn didn't happen and then it was
Martin's turn yeah coaching by Dusty May
to get his two best guys
looks right there off the bounce
that was a beautiful move he Disturbed
it's an incredible shot too I mean
that's a that's a tough shot to make
full speed guy on your hip reverse layup
a little English on that thing
wow that's a beautiful tag
all right
so now both teams also have like three
timeouts so this is going to be like
possession timeout possession
still going a little well we gotta see
if Golden's in the game gotta see our
matchups
yeah can we see the Huddle yeah I want
to look at the huddles you don't need to
you don't need a bad three right now
I've seen too many possessions or too
many plays in this tournament where it's
a close game and they they Hemorrhage an
awful look you need to get a quality
shot an easy back basket something
because it's not like FAU is scoring
every time they come down the floor yeah
[Applause]
and this stadium has filled out
I was a little worried I was too it was
a little bit sparse there early but
it's a great crowd now
all right so coming out that is golden
right yeah Golden's out there so golden
is out there
and I would have golden out there too he
has a lot of size yeah
there you go there it is literally the
play we wanted but he pulls up oh he
knocks down the jumping time but it was
the lady golden matchup at another
timeout
that was a good call whoever commented
and said the last two minutes is going
to take a lifetime they were correct now
gold with a little gamble there kind of
got him off balance and that's where you
got to be solid man not a tough matchup
for him though I would go right back to
that play if they need a bucket to win
the game I go right back to that what's
the D got 12 5-12 from the field
yeah I'm with that
Zibby commented new rule only lefko can
call the fouls
officials Taco tacos what's a dho
dribble handoff triple handoff
uh Lord nutmeg bird of prey are scared
of psychos don't sweat it Big T
uh
[Applause]
all right
so we we kind of think it's gonna be
just a two-man game for FAU well Davis
do you foul here I mean it's only a six
second differential if you don't I mean
oh that's fascinating this is one of
those talk through that walk through
that if you play this out and you get
the rebound and they take it all the way
down there will be 6.2 seconds to go so
wow a lot of coaches it's about do you
extend the game here
and it looks like what time would you
foul well if you're gonna do it you
would do it early if they're not going
to foul in the first in the next three
seconds they're going to play this out
wow
here we go boys final four live
presented by Wendy's 23 seconds and
counting
FAU
X
that's a lot of time then they call a
timeout FAU calls the timeout
do you like not following there
yeah I do yeah
um
it would be a debate I would have with
the assistant coaches but I think you
could go either way it's a definite gray
area there's no right or wrong answer
there
I Do Believe in a Thing Called over
coaching where you let the analytics and
a lot of other where you try to get a
little cute with your coaching style and
you try to be fancy and then you can you
know put yourself in a very bad
situation I I think just old school
trust your defense structure rotations
get the rebound and then come down and
try to get a uh but if you're FAU and
you score here you're definitely fouling
correct up three if it's a live ball
I don't know coaches are super what
nervous someone's gonna get the shot off
well just they don't you'll see a lot of
coaches they'll only foul if they can
call a timeout and set their defense to
tell everybody to get on the same page
it can be chaotic at the end of the game
and that coaches get uncomfortable with
that here we come
a game in the 70s was supposedly a game
that San Diego State did not want to
play but they are in it down one against
FAU 11 seconds on the shot clock the
owls inbounding and they use another
timeout wow
man
I ain't got none
they have no timeouts left so they get
the ball back with about six depending
on yep I think you go right towards the
basket I'm not sure you have time to
draw a play because you want to take a
shot where you can get the offensive
rebound for a putback I would honestly
if if if Bradley's in I give it to him
to just take a direct line drive to the
basket
[Music]
because every time he's gone he's either
scored or gotten fouled yep uh blackout
commenting thank God for this commentary
these timeouts are killing me that's the
uh the new bonus of this show is when
the teams save all of their timeouts to
the last minute we got your boy we
haven't even had any reviews I mean
that's where this can get really crazy
well we did have elbow games we did but
that was not in the last couple of
minutes
and you know that technical that they
called oh my God that this is where we
start talking like was it worth it yeah
yeah that was a five-point possession on
foul shots yeah right the thing that I'm
always worried about too is San Diego
State want to get down the floor so fast
that they don't rebound if it is a
missed shot
all right they got their big lineup Out
There Our ropes out there Keyshawn
Johnson's out there and Menses out there
both teams in the double bonus any foul
is two free throws no timeouts left for
Florida Atlantic one for the Aztecs of
San Diego State
my partner said I want to watch it live
there we go
FAU inbounding
it's Davis yes it's a Davis same play
cross them up good D Byron D rebound
eight seconds left they Advance the ball
no timeout
Good Deed he's got shoot it oh man
Butler oh
oh my God
unbelievable unbelievable what a shot
the dribble kids I mean they contain the
box he still made it wow
wow
unbelievable
Butler
the butler did it
unbelievable he balled against that was
the worst possible drama I was stuck on
the Baseline he had nowhere to go Tyler
hansbrough's yelling shoot it like he
forgot because he I thought he did I
thought he forgot there's been too many
possessions where they just dribble and
don't even get a shot off
you know what though he kept his dribble
alive wow and that allowed him one more
look on this screen again six seconds
left and he's just sitting there but a
lot of guys would have picked their
dribble up there and he went between the
legs and got one more that's a that's a
big time by Lamont brother a game in the
70s as a game San Diego State can't win
forget about it forget about the free
throw with the elbow forget about all of
them it doesn't matter man wow
the buzz in this place off game winners
when there's this many oh here it's
pretty sick that's and the energy that
this is going to bring to the second
game too absolutely wow
that was awesome
FAU fans got to be sick up 14 in the
second half complete control
and I can say that as an Eagles fan that
was at the Super Bowl I know what it's
like to sit in those chairs the only
difference is here
they're going to go to that student
section and they're gonna go hey we need
to move you out because we got to bring
in the concert section thanks for coming
I didn't get kicked out that's something
else
and then look at the San Diego State
kids losing their minds and listen to
what's playing Oh California Love
California man what a game wow
FAU had this
wow what a moment for San Diego State
what a moment
wow
all right guys wrap it up for me what
what do you take away from this it was
more than just the one shot it ended on
the one shot but how do you take in what
everything you just witnessed I can't
believe they won they missed foul shots
they didn't make they didn't make shots
really down the stretch but their
defense gives them a chance all the time
yeah the way they guard I mean the FAU
gets to 71. they were at 60 with I swear
it was like 14 like 10 minutes left
their defense locked in and then that
played by Lamont Butler so many guards
would panic and take a crazy shot on the
Baseline but to keep his dribble alive
have a presence of Mind of how much
time's left between the legs one dribble
and just rise up over the top of Nick
Boyd is that's an elite Play Tyler
what'd you see
first of all that shot was unbelievable
and the form on his shot impeccable yeah
but I want to say that San Diego State
stayed in it they chipped away and they
made the game uh the way that they
played the way that they play is they're
going to grind it out beat you up
defensively make the game ugly they
don't have a guy that they go to that
averages 20 25 points it's a whole
Collective effort and so they get things
done the old school way defensively
controlling the rebounds and that's what
they turned this game into which allowed
them to get this win
the coach of San Diego State
Mr Brian Dutcher was an assistant for
Michigan with the Fab Five when they
went to the finals against North
Carolina and lost that game
I have a feel in the entire fab five is
going to come from Monday night to
support their all coach who helped
recruit all those guys San Diego State
advances the number four ranked defense
in the country and they will take on the
winner of Uconn Miami UConn the top
rated team Miami one of the top rated
offenses and guess what this energy
continues we will be back in a little
bit to take you through that next game
final four live presented by Wendy's
will continue but what you have
witnessed Butler draining it at the end
we will be watching that for years to
come go get some Wendy's go get that
Frosty and we will see you back in a few
minutes wow San Diego State dances on
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign